Hey guys, what's up? Hey, how's it going? Uh... Hey, we're about to do a show. Sorry, I'm just trying to be quick. I'm trying to move, you know, with a lacquer team. Okay. Yep.
嘿大家，最近怎么样？嘿，过得好吗？呃……嘿，我们马上要开始录节目了。抱歉，我只是想快点。我想，你知道的，跟上团队的节奏。好的。没错。
Let's do it. Okay. So, I'm Sean. I'm Will. Are we late for our guest or something? No, it's just we gotta get to the show. It's like people are waiting to get to the show and then they gotta get through this BS first.
开始吧。好的。我是肖恩。我是威尔。我们是不是迟到了，还是怎么着？不，只是我们得开始录节目了。就像人们等着看节目，却得先听我们这些废话。
So, like, we're trying to get to the thing. It's smart list. Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go. What if people are watching this at night and they are listening to it at night and they're watching anything? They're not watching anything. Just fuckin' start to share them all. Bug on the switch.
所以，我们得赶紧进入正题。是SmartLess。走走走走走走走。如果有人晚上看这个，或者晚上听这个，他们能看到什么？他们什么也看不到。赶紧开始分享吧。别管那个开关了。
Smart. Lost. Smart. Lost. Smart. Lost. Smart. Lost.
Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。
Listener, Will's in a, what we call a whisper booth in the biz, where he's got a sort sort of a fold up, sort of a fabric closet that he can get, you know, he can do all his video work remotely, wherever he is on the planet. For some reason, he's got a white stick, one that a person without sight might use. What do you use, right? What is that for?
听众朋友们，威尔现在在一个我们行话叫“隔音间”的地方，他有一个折叠式的、布料做的衣柜，这样他无论在地球的哪个角落，都能远程完成他的视频工作。不知为何，他拿了一根白手杖，就是那种视障人士可能会用的那种。你用那个干嘛？那是干什么用的？
Go ahead, Will. It's a light. Oh, it's a light. For what? It's a light yourself? No, it's just like a light fixture that I don't use, and it's in the background. So sometimes you see this part, the white part of it,
你说吧，威尔。那是个灯。哦，是个灯。干什么用的？那是你自己的灯吗？不，那只是一个我没用的灯具，它在背景里。所以有时候你会看到这个部分，白色的那部分，
and it makes Jason crazy. Not sometimes, always. Sean, I don't know if you noticed, we had a meeting the other day, the three of us with somebody else, right? And during the meeting, I did, I saw it out of the corner of my eye, and I brought it into frame,
这让杰森很抓狂。不是有时候，是总是。肖恩，我不知道你有没有注意到，前几天我们三个人和别人开会的时候，对吧？在会议期间，我用余光看到了它，我就把它挪进了镜头里，
just because I knew it made Jason crazy. Listen, it will, obviously. It is not your fault, you're doing nothing wrong. I'm just, it's more of a comment on how crazy I am. Wow, this is unbelievable growth from you. Yeah, yeah. Right, Sean? I kind of wish it wasn't a lamp.
就因为我知道这会让杰森抓狂。听着，威尔，很明显。这不是你的错，你没做错什么。我只是，这更多是说明我有多疯狂。哇，你这真是不可思议的成长。是啊，是啊。对吧，肖恩？我倒希望那不是个灯。
I wish it was something else, that you needed it to get something from off a high shelf or something. Oh, right. Maybe you were losing your sight, and you just wanted to have the stick nearby, in case it takes full hold at some point. In just case, yeah. No, no, no, I mean, I'm blessing that way.
我希望那是别的东西，比如你需要它从高架子上拿东西之类的。哦，对。也许你视力在下降，你只是想把手杖放在身边，以防万一哪天真的看不见了。以防万一，是啊。不不不，我是说，我还没到那种程度。
Sorry, Sean, I feel like you've got something you really need to talk about. I do, I really want to say, I really got some really great news. I got an antibodies test yesterday to see where I am with my antibodies off the charts. Really? Super strong antibodies.
抱歉，肖恩，我觉得你有话一定要说。我有，我真的想说，我真的有个非常棒的消息。我昨天做了抗体测试，看看我的抗体水平，结果爆表了。真的吗？超级强力的抗体。
Did you guys get tested? I did, I got tested recently. You get tested all the time? No, no, but for your antibodies. Is that a separate test? Yeah. Yes, yeah, I have been tested for antibodies. It's good, right?
你们去测试了吗？我测了，我最近测过。你一直都在做测试吗？不，不，我是说你的抗体。那是单独的测试吗？对。是的，我做过抗体测试。这很好，对吧？
It's good, I mean, you've been vaccinated. Makes me feel real safe. Yeah, I'm vaccinated. Where is Sean's vaccinated? No, I know, but the antibodies are the next thing. I vaccinated Sean. He doesn't trust anybody with a needle but me. Right.
很好，我是说，你已经接种过疫苗了。这让我感觉很安全。是的，我接种了。肖恩接种了吗？不，我知道，但抗体是下一步。我给肖恩接种了。除了我，他不相信任何人拿针。对。
And he does it, he comes over at night to put me to sleep with some extra, special something. Yeah, yeah. What is it, Will? I don't know. Go ahead, let's get the rest out. I can't.
而且他确实这么做了，他晚上过来给我打点什么特别的东西，让我睡觉。是啊，是啊。那是什么，威尔？我不知道。继续吧，把剩下的说完。我不能。
And you guys do that on a drip, or is it a tablet or? No, it's a drip, it's a drip. Does he ever cook it up for you? And you use some of it? A spoon? Yeah, sometimes. You guys are the worst.
你们是滴注，还是吃药片？不，是滴注，是滴注。他会为你准备吗？你用勺子吗？是啊，有时候。你们真是太糟糕了。
You're the worst. Yeah. I miss you guys. I gotta say, I really miss you guys. I know we haven't seen each other, and I'm sorry, I miss you too. You guys are warming me up. I've come onto this episode in a bad mood this morning.
你们真是太糟糕了。是啊。我想你们了。我得说，我真的很想你们。我知道我们没见过面，抱歉，我也想你们。你们让我感觉温暖多了。我今天早上带着坏心情来录这期节目。
No, it's okay, well listen, I love you guys, and I'm happy that we have, that our guest today is some, I'm really excited about it. Hopefully this guest is Array of Sunshine, can bring me from my culture. Well, I can say he is. Now, I've never met this guy,
不，没关系，听着，我爱你们，我很高兴我们今天的嘉宾是……我真的很兴奋。希望这位嘉宾是一缕阳光，能把我从坏心情中拉出来。嗯，我可以肯定他是。现在，我还没见过这家伙，
but from what I know, he is Array of Sunshine. Is that what it said on his breakdown when you swipe left? That's what it said. That's the first line in his profile. Hello, I'm Array of Sunshine. I've been, I'm a fan of this guy for a while now, and Jason, you're kind of responsible for it in a way,
但据我所知，他就是一缕阳光。你在左滑的时候，他的简介上是这么写的吗？就是这么写的。那是他个人资料里的第一行。你好，我是一缕阳光。我关注这家伙有一阵子了，杰森，这在某种程度上要归功于你，
and you'll find out why in a second. And I'm so excited, and I kept asking, like, what is the day that he's coming on? What's the day he's coming on? Cause I'm so excited, he's got great energy about him, which is one of the things I really liked when I was watching him do what he does, was his energy. But on top of that, he's really good at what he does.
一会儿你就知道为什么了。我太兴奋了，我一直问，他哪天来？他哪天来？因为我太兴奋了，他身上有很棒的能量，这也是我当初看他工作时最喜欢的一点，就是他的能量。而且最重要的是，他真的很擅长他的工作。
In fact, he's incredible, and I can't imagine doing what he does. Our friend is an Australian, he's from Down Under. David Blaine. No, he has won a number of big championships in what it is that he does. He has been at the top of his game for 10 years since he moved from Australia to Europe to pursue
事实上，他简直不可思议，我无法想象他做的事情。我们的朋友是澳大利亚人，他来自遥远的南方。大卫·布莱恩。不，他在他所从事的领域赢得了许多重大冠军。自从他从澳大利亚搬到欧洲追求成为世界最伟大的赛车手以来，他已经在巅峰状态保持了10年。
becoming the world's greatest race car driver. He's won so many Grand Prix, including the Monaco Grand Prix. I don't want to wait any longer, our guest is Daniel Riccardo. Oh my God. Geez Louise. Driver, Daniel! Oh my goodness, look at this. This is a big star, you guys.
他赢得了许多大奖赛，包括摩纳哥大奖赛。我不想再等了，我们的嘉宾是丹尼尔·里卡多。天哪。天呐。车手，丹尼尔！天哪，看看这个。这是个大明星，伙计们。
This is, I am star struck. Wow. Will, you must be, Will, do you have anything on underneath frame, at all? It's just the shirt today, I'll bet, right? God, Will's a big F1 fan, listen. Do you know each other from before? No, we've never met.
这是，我被惊艳到了。哇。威尔，你一定，威尔，你镜头下面穿衣服了吗？肯定只有衬衫吧，对吧？天哪，威尔是个F1大粉丝，听着。你们以前认识吗？不，我们从没见过。
Wow. Daniel, what a pleasure. Let me just start by saying Daniel, welcome to our, welcome to SmartList. We're so excited to have you. It's a pleasure to meet you. How are you? I'm very well.
哇。丹尼尔，真是荣幸。让我先说一句，丹尼尔，欢迎来到我们的节目，欢迎来到SmartLess。我们很高兴你能来。很高兴见到你。你好吗？我很好。
I'm very well, thanks. This is awesome. That was quite an intro, and I've got pressure on now. I'm supposed to be a ray of sunshine, so I'll give it my best. Look at the smile. Look at the teeth and the smile. What a great smile, you guys.
我很好，谢谢。这太棒了。这开场白真不错，我现在压力很大。我得表现得像一缕阳光，我会尽力的。看看这笑容。看看这牙齿和笑容。真是个很棒的笑容，伙计们。
Your smile is incredible. It's the greatest smile in Formula One, potentially, in all of sport. So much so that you should be allowed to race without a helmet, just so we don't, just so we can see it. Always, going around the turns, smiling. 200 miles an hour.
你的笑容太不可思议了。这可能是F1，甚至整个体育界最棒的笑容。以至于你应该被允许不戴头盔比赛，这样我们就能看到它。总是这样，过弯的时候还在笑。时速200英里。
Yeah, they love it. Oh my God, so what part of the world do we have you in? Listener, if you're not familiar with Formula One, these rock stars travel around the world to do these races every other weekend, I wanna say, because they wouldn't be able to do it every weekend because the apparatus that they have to put on these big, huge 747s, I think you get a 747 per team.
是啊，他们喜欢这样。天哪，你现在在世界的哪个角落？听众朋友们，如果你不熟悉F1，这些摇滚明星每隔一个周末就会飞往世界各地参加比赛，我想说，因为他们不可能每个周末都跑，因为他们必须把设备装上那些巨大的747飞机，我想每个车队有一架747。
We're gonna find out. We're gonna find out. But I mean, anyway, so where are you in the world? I'm in Monaco at the moment. So Monaco's like, it's a little bit of a hub for... Tax Haven? I guess, race car drivers and that. Yeah.
我们会弄清楚的。我们会弄清楚的。但总之，你在世界的哪个角落？我现在在摩纳哥。所以摩纳哥有点像是一个……避税天堂？我想，赛车手之类的。是啊。
Any other athletes live there? Any other rich people looking to save a bit there? There's a lot of cyclists and tennis players. Yeah, and a lot of German counts and stuff like that. So Daniel, so you're in Monaco, that's your home base. You grew up in Australia. You grew up in Perth, Australia, right, on the West Coast. And you got into, tell us a little bit about how you got in,
还有其他运动员住在那儿吗？还有其他想省点钱的富人吗？有很多自行车手和网球运动员。是啊，还有很多德国伯爵之类的。所以丹尼尔，你在摩纳哥，那是你的大本营。你在澳大利亚长大。你在澳大利亚珀斯长大，对吧，在西海岸。你是怎么进入的，告诉我们一点你是怎么进入的，
how do you become a Formula One driver? Yeah, I wanna know everything. A person who is in Perth, Australia to Formula One, what was that trajectory? Like how old were you when you started, et cetera? Yeah, it's absolutely one of the most weird sports. So it basically started in go-karting. Oh, really?
你是怎么成为F1车手的？是啊，我想知道一切。一个在澳大利亚珀斯的人是怎么进入F1的，那个轨迹是什么样的？你开始的时候多大，等等？是啊，这绝对是最奇怪的运动之一。它基本上是从卡丁车开始的。哦，真的吗？
But it was more like, as a kid, like I loved, I just liked going fast. Like I loved the adrenaline of, even if it was like riding a push bike down a hill, like all that sort of stuff. I was just like, let me go fast because that's what I enjoy to do. And when I was, yeah, like eight, nine years old,
但更像是，小时候，我喜欢，我只是喜欢开快车。我喜欢那种肾上腺素，即使是骑自行车下坡，诸如此类。我当时就是，让我开快点，因为那是我喜欢做的。当我，是的，大概八九岁的时候，
I basically begged mom and dad to get me a go-kart. And at the time it was just to like, maybe after school some days, they'll take me down to the track and just let off some steam. But let me ask you this, even before that, cause they all look like hot wheels, right? They all look like those little kind of cars that you raced like at home.
我基本上求着爸妈给我买辆卡丁车。当时只是想，也许放学后，他们带我去赛道，让我发泄一下。但我问你这个，在那之前，因为它们看起来都像风火轮，对吧？它们看起来都像你在家里玩的那种小车。
Did you ever play with those? Oh yeah, yeah, I was like a massive nerd for that sort of stuff. So it went from that to go-karts? Okay. But were you a kid, like when you were a baby, I'll tell you why I'm asking this. So my toddler, my son, who's 14 months old,
你玩过那些吗？哦，是的，是的，我当时是个超级书呆子。所以是从那个转到卡丁车的？好的。但你小时候，比如你还是个婴儿的时候，我告诉你我为什么要问这个。我的幼儿，我14个月大的儿子，
and I have two older boys, I've never seen anything like it. He's obsessed with, his first word was car. He wakes up in the morning, he points to outside, he wants to go in the car and I'm not joking. The last two weeks has been, I take him out and he wants to sit in the driver's seat and he holds onto the steering wheel
我有两个大儿子，我从没见过这样的。他痴迷于，他的第一个词是“车”。他早上醒来，指着外面，他想去车里，我没开玩笑。过去两周，我带他出去，他想坐在驾驶座上，他抓着方向盘，
and he's good for 25 minutes. And he says like four words, it's all he wants is to be in a car. What was the second word? Lawsuit. Lawsuit. Lawsuit, strangely. So Will, you're in trouble.
他能乖乖坐25分钟。他只会说四个词，他想要的只是在车里。第二个词是什么？诉讼。诉讼。奇怪的是，诉讼。所以威尔，你有麻烦了。
Not for the lawsuit, for the car stuff. Yeah. And I kind of left out some information in the first part is so my dad loved cars. He raced a little bit, not professionally, but just as a hobby, I guess. Sean, your dad was pretty good at driving pretty fast away from the home.
不是因为诉讼，是因为车的事情。是啊。我第一部分漏掉了一些信息，我爸爸喜欢车。他赛过一点车，不是职业的，只是作为爱好，我想。肖恩，你爸爸在开车远离家门方面挺厉害的。
Sorry. Some say, some say if you listen closely, you can hear still. You can hear the engine receding. You're like away. Yeah, the screech carries. Yeah. Go ahead.
抱歉。有人说，有人说如果你仔细听，你还能听到。你还能听到引擎远去的声音。你就像离开了。是啊，那刺耳声还在。是啊。继续。
Even before I came on, I was just listening obviously and I was, I could listen and just, I'm sure you guys have a lot of banter, let's say. We're just such bored people with very and too much caffeine in us. The most boring, dumb people on the planet. Three narcissists that like to hear their own voice. So your dad.
甚至在我上来之前，我显然就在听，我当时，我肯定你们有很多玩笑，可以说。我们只是非常无聊的人，带着太多咖啡因。地球上最无聊、最愚蠢的人。三个喜欢听自己声音的自恋者。所以你爸爸。
We're not even letting you talk. Please. So your dad was into racing a little bit, not professionally, and you were like, at an early age, you're like, let me upstage my dad. Go on, continue. Your words. Yeah, so I guess the truth is,
我们甚至没让你说话。请。所以你爸爸对赛车有点兴趣，不是职业的，你当时，在很小的时候，你就想，让我超越我爸爸。继续，继续。你自己说的。是啊，我想事实是，
if he had the opportunity to race when he was young, I'm sure he would have. Like it was, it was his passion and still to this day, like he knows more about cars than I do. Like he's, he's the proper, proper enthusiast. And I'm, I mean, loves to, I mean, I, yeah, I won't sell myself short. I grew up watching it on TV when I was.
如果他年轻时有机会赛车，我相信他会去的。这曾经是，现在依然是他的热情所在，他比我更懂车。他是个真正的、真正的发烧友。我是说，喜欢，我是说，我，是的，我不会妄自菲薄。我从小就在电视上看比赛。
You did. Yeah, probably like your son at two, three years old. And it was like the noise. It was the, and then if I'll go to the racetrack to watch dad, it was the smell. Like there was so many, so many kinds of sensors that I was just in love with. Yeah.
你看了。是啊，大概像你儿子两三岁的时候。那是那种噪音。那是，如果我去赛道看爸爸比赛，那是那种气味。有太多太多的感官让我沉迷其中。是啊。
Jason, you like, you like to smell, you like to sniff what we call a sniff gasoline, right? That was a big. It's actually, it's huffing, but. That's how it gets up in the morning. Right. And then, and Sean, and then you're, you're sent, there was alcohol, right?
杰森，你喜欢，你喜欢闻，你喜欢嗅我们所谓的“嗅汽油”，对吧？那是个大问题。其实是吸入，但是。那是他早上起床的方式。对。然后，肖恩，然后你，你送，有酒精，对吧？
And then the sound of the door shutting, and then, and then the exhaust, you can smell the exhaust as you eat it. And just a very distant, fuck you. Wait, so Daniel, so, so, so you do go karting, your parents take you out, all of a sudden, what age was it that people in Perth were like, you know, check this guy.
然后是关门的声音，然后，然后是排气管，你吃的时候能闻到排气味。还有一个非常遥远的，去你的。等等，所以丹尼尔，所以，所以你玩卡丁车，你父母带你去，突然之间，珀斯的人是在什么年纪觉得，你知道，看看这家伙。
He's gotten really, really fast. This guy should be kind of formula one. Like what was that moment that people had that conversation in his accent? Just like I did. Yeah. Who said crikey first? Yes.
他变得非常非常快。这家伙应该去F1。人们是在什么时刻用那种口音进行那次谈话的？就像我刚才那样。谁先说的“Crikey”？是的。
Who said this Bogan should be racing overseas? Your accent's good. So yeah, from when I was pretty much born, I had a passion for it and I love for it. But I think even through like my teenage years, so I was racing go-karts, but I wasn't, maybe I didn't have like massive self-confidence at that point.
谁说这个乡巴佬应该去海外比赛的？你的口音不错。所以，是的，从我出生起，我就对它有热情，有爱。但我认为即使在我十几岁的时候，我当时在跑卡丁车，但我没有，也许我当时没有那种巨大的自信。
I was winning some races, but I wasn't the, I wasn't like dominating the Australian scene, so to speak. I was one of like the guys, but not the one. So then I was, I was kind of like, all right, if I'm not like dominating in Australia, how am I gonna take it to Europe, where the real like hub is for motorsport,
我赢了一些比赛，但我不是，我没有像统治澳大利亚赛场那样。我是其中之一，但不是那个最强的。所以我当时想，好吧，如果我在澳大利亚没有统治力，我怎么去欧洲，那里才是赛车运动真正的中心，
at least for Formula One related. So I basically got to, I was probably like 16, and I was really, I was enjoying racing more than anything else I was doing. And at school, I wasn't, I wasn't really... Focusing on your studies. Sorry. You weren't really focusing on your studies?
至少对F1来说。所以我基本上到了，我大概16岁的时候，我比做任何其他事情都更享受赛车。在学校，我没有，我没有真的……专注于你的学业。抱歉。你没有专注于你的学业？
Well, I tried, kind of. You're looking at me really seriously. Well, no, I mean, Jason, listen, honestly, for Jason, his studies were in the back of a trailer on the Warner Brothers lot. So like, that was, he understands what, how... I'm saying, you know, make sure you're in your key light and don't shadow the other actor
嗯，我试过了，算是吧。你看着我真的很严肃。嗯，不，我是说，杰森，听着，老实说，对杰森来说，他的学业是在华纳兄弟片场的拖车后面完成的。所以，他明白，如何……我是说，确保你在主光里，不要遮住其他演员，
and all that other stuff. Yeah, and, you know, lunchtime, going into grace, he understood all this stuff as part of his school experience. So you're not striving at school, you're 16, you're not the number one guy in Australia. Are you even the number one guy in Western Australia? I was definitely up there.
还有所有那些东西。是啊，而且，你知道，午餐时间，去格蕾丝那里，他把所有这些都当作他学校经历的一部分。所以你在学校表现不佳，你16岁，你不是澳大利亚的第一人。你甚至是西澳大利亚的第一人吗？我绝对名列前茅。
Like I was in the group, and I guess then, I guess long story short, I probably hit a point where I'd kind of just start like finishing school, 16, 17. And I kind of flipped a bit of a switch in terms of just like personal maturity. I kind of grew up and I was quite like young immatural. Oh, what's that like? I'm still figuring it out.
就像我在那个群体里，我想然后，长话短说，我可能到了一个点，我刚开始结束学业，16、17岁。我在个人成熟度方面有点转变。我当时有点年轻，不成熟。哦，那是什么感觉？我还在摸索。
How old are you now? 32. Okay, same. And then I had kind of, there was a moment where I was like, all right, I'm gonna go all in on this. And I did like a one-off race in Europe. And I think that was my, in a way, my fear was kind of thinking
你现在多大？32岁。好的，一样。然后我有一种，有一个时刻，我当时想，好吧，我要全力以赴。我做了一次欧洲的比赛。我想那是我的，在某种程度上，我的恐惧是认为
that the European guys was so much better. And I kind of had no chance. And I surprised myself when I did this race. I finished fifth out of, I don't know, probably 35. And it was kind of like the best of my age group at the time. And then that was like, all right. So I moved to Europe the following year and basically went all in.
欧洲的家伙们强太多了。我基本上没机会。当我参加那场比赛时，我让自己大吃一惊。我在大概35人中获得了第五名。那是我当时同龄人中最好的。然后那是，好吧。所以第二年我搬到了欧洲，基本上全力以赴。
You're one of those people, this is the heart of a champion. You needed more competition. You needed, because those, you weren't getting it. And look, this is not a slight to your countrymen down in Oz, but it kind of is. They weren't giving you the competition that you needed. You needed to go to the big leagues.
你是那种人，这就是冠军的心。你需要更多的竞争。你需要，因为那些，你没得到。听着，这不是对你在澳洲的同胞的轻视，但某种程度上也是。他们没给你需要的竞争。你需要去大联盟。
And once you got there, that kind of, it kind of awoke something inside you. And you're like, oh, I can do this. And once you had that first taste of success, it probably, you probably never looked back a little bit in terms of confidence, right? I'm guessing. Yeah, like 100%, that race gave me so much more.
一旦你到了那里，那种，它唤醒了你内心的东西。你当时想，哦，我可以做到。一旦你尝到了第一次成功的滋味，它可能，在自信方面，你可能再也没回头，对吧？我猜。是啊，百分之百，那场比赛给了我更多。
Because like for us, we put like Europe on a pedestal as far as the motor racing. And so when I was like, yeah, I was kind of convinced myself I could do it. So then when I moved to Europe, I was like, I was so disciplined, so strict. And a few other guys, whether they were from Australia or from other parts of the world, let's say not Europe,
因为对我们来说，我们把欧洲放在赛车运动的基座上。所以当我当时，是的，我有点说服自己我能做到。所以当我搬到欧洲时，我当时，我非常自律，非常严格。还有其他几个家伙，无论他们是来自澳大利亚还是世界其他地方，我们说不是欧洲，
there were some young kids who were kind of living, I was living in Italy at the time. And there was a few living there as well. There was like a training kind of facility. And yeah, like I could see the tendency, like, okay, we're away from family, away from our parents, we're 17 years old. And there was a bit of partying and this and that.
有一些年轻人，我当时住在意大利。还有一些人也住在那里。有一个训练设施。是啊，我能看到那种倾向，好吧，我们远离家人，远离父母，我们17岁。有一些派对，这个那个。
And I was just, I was like, no. I'm here to win. Yeah, I don't know. I just, as I said, I kind of flipped a switch. And yeah, that was the best. I wanna go back to, because you think I'm joking, but I'm not, I really, really, really do wanna do one of those things where you buy like an hour
我当时只是，我当时想，不。我是来赢的。是啊，我不知道。我只是，正如我所说，我有点转变了。是的，那是最好的。我想回到，因为你以为我在开玩笑，但我没有，我真的，真的，真的想做那种你买一个小时
around a racetrack or something. You know, you go to those racetracks and you can race yourself. And I really do wanna try that. What was that like the very, very first time? Did you do it at your dad's, where your dad raced? Like, did you get in a car by yourself? And he said, okay, great, let's just try this.
在赛道上跑之类的事情。你知道，你去那些赛道，你可以自己赛车。我真的想试试。第一次是什么感觉？你在你爸爸赛车的地方做的吗？就像，你独自坐进车里？他说，好的，太棒了，让我们试试这个。
And what was that like? So it's like the one word of all associate racing with is freedom, especially at a young age. You know, like you're controlling this machine. And even though like you got a helmet on, you know, you still get some like, some of the wind in your face. And it's like, it's a free feeling. And that's what it was.
那是什么感觉？所以这就像我把赛车联系在一起的一个词是自由，尤其是在年轻的时候。你知道，你在控制这台机器。即使你戴着头盔，你知道，你还是能感觉到一些风吹在脸上。这是一种自由的感觉。这就是它的感觉。
Talk to me about the euphoria of freedom and controlling that machine and gliding through the turns. You have to marry that with a management of fear too, because to really compete, you've gotta sort of live on that sort of the limits of adhesion, right? Where the tire will sort of, you're pressing it too far and the tire loses adhesion to the road and you spin off and you'll hit the wall.
跟我说说那种自由的快感，控制那台机器，在弯道中滑行。你必须把它与对恐惧的管理结合起来，因为要真正竞争，你必须生活在那种附着力的极限上，对吧？轮胎会，你压得太狠，轮胎失去了对路面的附着力，你就会打滑撞墙。
So you have to constantly feel that literally in your seat, where the car is and risk going just a little bit further, a little bit deeper into the turn, all this stuff. How do you, is it, are you just not worried about it? How did, tell me about it. Yeah, and by the way, Daniel, and Jason knows this because he actually won the Long Beach Celebrity. He beat Richard Klein from Threes Company
所以你必须不断地在座位上感觉到，车在哪里，并冒着风险再深入一点，再晚一点进弯，所有这些。你怎么，是，你只是不担心吗？告诉我关于这个。是啊，顺便说一句，丹尼尔，杰森知道这一点，因为他确实赢得了长滩名人赛。他击败了《三人行》的理查德·克莱恩
and Tommy Cattain in the qualifying. It was incredible, I don't know if you've seen the replay. I think you're actually right with those names. He's done a little bit of racing himself, but so. Back before gasoline was invented. But what is that fear? Is that real? So I'm not blowing smoke,
和汤米·卡坦在排位赛中。太不可思议了，我不知道你有没有看过重播。我想你说的那些名字是对的。他自己也赛过一点车，但是。在汽油发明之前。但那种恐惧是什么？那是真的吗？所以我不是在吹牛，
but the way you put that forward was beautiful. Like I would have guessed you were an engineer or something, that was, how did you? I started at Pirelli and then I discovered acting, but. I'm confused because that was really, that was quite, quite something. Well, I am always interested how you can tell when you drive with somebody, whether they are,
但你提出这一点的方式很美。我本来会猜你是个工程师之类的，那是，你怎么？我从倍耐力开始，然后我发现了表演，但是。我很困惑，因为那真的，那真是太棒了。嗯，我一直对你如何判断当你和某人一起开车时，他们是否是，
when they're steering a car, whether they're trying to literally just stay in between the lanes. And so they're constantly adjusting the wheel to stay in the middle of the lane, where some people drive, they're looking much further down the road and they're just kind of generally going in that direction
当他们驾驶汽车时，他们是否真的只是试图保持在车道中间。所以他们不断调整方向盘以保持在车道中间，而有些人开车，他们看得更远，他们只是大致朝着那个方向前进，
and they're kind of gliding a little bit. And they're kind of at one with the car. You can just see it just driving around on the streets. And is that kind of how you, you can just kind of marry yourself to that seat and the whole car and you are one thing or is it much more technical than that? No, you've basically nailed it.
他们有点在滑行。他们与车合二为一。你可以在街上开车时看到它。这是否就是你，你可以把自己和那个座位以及整辆车结合在一起，你们是一个整体，还是说这比那更技术性？不，你基本上说对了。
That's really good awareness. So we have, yeah, you should piss pump. Yeah, I was just great. I guess, I mean, what the fuck are you talking about? By the way, I know you live in Los Angeles part of the time. So next time you, if you feel like some eyes burning in the back of your head is Jason watching you drive.
那是非常好的意识。所以我们有，是啊，你应该……是啊，我刚才太棒了。我猜，我是说，你在说什么鬼话？顺便说一句，我知道你有一部分时间住在洛杉矶。所以下次你，如果你觉得后脑勺有灼热的目光，那是杰森在看你开车。
I just watch you. So tell me what you do with that fear. What do you do with that fear? You just put it behind you because you can't win with it? Yeah, pretty much. I think because, I mean, the first time you get into a go-kart, so for me, eight years old, you're aware of already like the risk and the danger.
我只是看着你。所以告诉我你如何处理那种恐惧。你如何处理那种恐惧？你只是把它抛在脑后，因为你不能带着它赢？是啊，差不多。我想因为，我是说，你第一次坐进卡丁车，对我来说，八岁，你已经意识到风险和危险了。
And so that fear is something now that I've called it, lived with my whole, let's say racing career. And it's somewhere in the back. And I think sometimes like you'd need a little bit of that fear. Let's access it today. Let's access the fear today. Let's get ready.
所以那种恐惧是我现在，可以说，整个赛车生涯都与之共存的东西。它在某个地方。我想有时候，你需要一点那种恐惧。让我们今天访问它。让我们今天访问那种恐惧。让我们准备好。
Will likes to make guests cry. What about when you're driving these really, really expensive cars? I mean, the go-karts were expensive at eight, I'm sure. But now you really have a good sense of what a dollar is worth. And these cars are multimillion dollar cars. You go into a turn and you get loose.
威尔喜欢让嘉宾哭。当你驾驶这些非常非常昂贵的车时呢？我是说，卡丁车在八岁时很贵，我肯定。但现在你真的对钱的价值有很好的认识。这些车是数百万美元的车。你进入一个弯道，你失控了。
There's hundreds of thousands of dollars of damage done on that car. What's that process like? I mean, obviously some crashes are assumed and there's a backup car and all that stuff. But the day after or the week after, is there ever like a little like, can we talk to you for a second? You know, the budget this year you've crashed four times.
那辆车有几十万美元的损失。那个过程是什么样的？我是说，显然有些撞车是预料之中的，有备用车之类的。但在第二天或一周后，有没有像“能跟你谈谈吗？你知道，今年的预算你撞了四次车。
It's cost us $14 million. Are you ever talked to about like your responsibility for the crashes and the money and all that stuff? Does that happen? Fortunately, I don't do it often. So I haven't had that. But that sounds really like arrogant stuff. No, but does it happen?
这花了我们1400万美元。”有人跟你谈过你对撞车和金钱的责任吗？这会发生吗？幸运的是，我不常这样做。所以我没遇到过。但这听起来真的很傲慢。不，但这会发生吗？
Do you hear about it in your industry that a driver will get pulled aside or be asked to leave a team because it's just costing them too much money? Yeah, I think there's like the difference of being reckless. And then there's the difference of exploring the limit. And I think a team will, especially in the early days, like a team will respect you for,
你在你的行业里听说过车手会被拉到一边，或者被要求离开车队，因为这花了他们太多钱吗？是啊，我想有鲁莽和探索极限的区别。我认为车队会，尤其是在早期，车队会尊重你，
okay, not crashing every weekend, but if you do have a crash every so often, but because you're testing the limit and really trying to get everything out of yourself in the car. Yeah, or that particular setup on the car with suspension or tires or whatever, they would go, oh, okay, you know,
好吧，不是每个周末都撞车，但如果你偶尔撞一次，是因为你在测试极限，真的试图从车里榨出你的一切。是啊，或者那个特定的悬挂或轮胎设置，他们会说，哦，好吧，你知道，
he's just trying to see where it goes. Speaking of that, so what do you think about, and again, we can totally take this out, Daniel, but just what do you think about a couple of weeks ago? I think it was at Silverstone when, you know, when Lewis made that move on Verstappen, and Verstappen ended up crashing out. Like that was a very aggressive move by Lewis
他只是在看极限在哪里。说到这个，你觉得，再说一次，我们可以完全剪掉这个，丹尼尔，但你觉得几周前怎么样？我想是在银石赛道，当，你知道，当刘易斯对维斯塔潘做出那个动作时，维斯塔潘最终撞车了。那是一个非常激进的动作，刘易斯
and people calling him out and saying that he did not make the right move in that moment. Well, they're racing in that moment. That's kind of what they're there to do. Do you agree with that? Or was, do you think somebody was being too aggressive? Let's get Sean's opinion first. Well, I want to know if you want to know
人们指责他，说他在那一刻没有做出正确的动作。嗯，他们在那一刻比赛。这就是他们在那里的目的。你同意吗？还是你认为有人太激进？让我们先听听肖恩的意见。嗯，我想知道如果你想知道
what race car backwards is. Uh-oh, here we come. Race car. Yeah, thanks. Hey! Go ahead and answer, Will's question. What's that called? That's called a palindrome? Yeah, yeah, great.
“赛车”倒过来是什么。呃哦，我们要来了。赛车。是啊，谢谢。嘿！继续回答，威尔的问题。那叫什么？那叫回文？是啊，是啊，太棒了。
That's all I was thinking about. Where's the part we'll cut out? So, but, you know, like, but it goes to sort of the crashing and stuff and being aggressive in those moments. And that was something that just happened the last couple of weeks. What do you think about aggressive driving like that? And, you know, like that particular moment?
我当时想的就是这个。威尔要剪掉的部分在哪里？所以，但是，你知道，就像，但它涉及到撞车之类的事情，在那些时刻表现得激进。那是过去几周刚刚发生的事情。你觉得那种激进驾驶怎么样？还有，你知道，那个特定的时刻？
So I'll go to that one, and then I'll kind of talk about it in general. So that one was, you'd call it like a racing incident, I think because, so those two have been going at it all year. So they're currently fighting for the championship and they've been pushing the absolute edge with each other. And it was kind of, I feel everyone felt like it was inevitable at some point.
所以我先说那个，然后我再谈谈一般情况。所以那个，你会称之为赛车事故，我想因为，所以他们两个整年都在较劲。所以他们目前在争夺冠军，他们一直在互相推向极限。感觉每个人都觉得这是不可避免的。
We got 20-something races this year. At some point, they're going to have a moment. So I think that was it. And it all obviously happened so quick. I mean, we've been doing it our whole life. So we need to be able to, let's say, cope with it. But yeah, there's still, there's a lot of, especially the first lap of the race, which it was,
我们今年有20多场比赛。在某个时刻，他们会发生碰撞。所以我认为就是那样。而且显然发生得太快了。我是说，我们一生都在做这个。所以我们需要能够，可以说，应对它。但是的，依然有，有很多，尤其是比赛的第一圈，也就是当时的情况，
that's like the most intense lap of the race. You know, you've got to start, you've got all kind of like the energy and the atmosphere of the crowd. You've got to get through that first turn, right, Sean? Yeah, you got to really pull it tight around the corner. Sean, you got to understand too, like for, and for Daniel, I don't want to speak for you,
那是比赛中最激烈的圈。你知道，你必须开始，你有各种各样的能量和人群的气氛。你必须通过那个第一弯，对吧，肖恩？是啊，你必须在弯道处把它拉紧。肖恩，你也得明白，就像对于，对于丹尼尔，我不想替你说话，
but so Daniel, he came up with a Toro Rosso, which is owned by Red Bull, and then became a Red Bull driver for a number of years and had success. In fact, one Monaco and a bunch of other races under driving for the Red Bull team. And then he moved and now he races for McLaren. So he has a history with those guys and with Max Verstappen.
但所以丹尼尔，他从红牛旗下的红牛二队出来，然后成为红牛车队的车手多年，并取得了成功。事实上，在红牛车队效力期间赢得了摩纳哥大奖赛和其他许多比赛。然后他转会了，现在他为迈凯伦效力。所以他和那些家伙以及马克斯·维斯塔潘有历史。
So there's like, you guys all know each other. You guys have been racing with, for, against each other. Like there's a lot of, it's like being in a big, huge extended family in a way, I bet, right? It is, and there's only, I mean, there's 20 of us in the world. Like there's 20 of one drivers per year.
所以就像，你们都认识彼此。你们一直在为，对，对抗彼此比赛。就像，这就像在一个巨大的大家庭里，我敢说，对吧？是啊，而且只有，我是说，世界上只有我们20个人。每年只有20个F1车手。
That's it, that's crazy. Maybe a couple of seats will get changed each year. So like you are spending a lot of time with kind of the current group. And yeah, you get to obviously, yeah, know each other a bit and listen to that. But I think being like over aggressive and all of that sort of stuff,
就是这样，太疯狂了。也许每年会有几个席位变动。所以你确实花了很多时间与当前的群体在一起。是啊，你显然，是啊，了解彼此一点，听听那个。但我认为过于激进和所有那些东西，
like that was actually one of my, let's say weaknesses or downfalls kind of growing up. And when I got to Formula One is, I was kind of intimidated just by being there and who I was racing against. And I wasn't aggressive enough. And I kind of got, I got kind of mauled a few times and it was kind of like, yeah, I can,
那实际上是我，可以说，成长过程中的弱点或挫折之一。当我进入F1时，我有点被我在那里以及我与谁比赛所吓倒。我不够激进。我被，我被蹂躏了几次，这就像，是啊，我可以，
if I qualify well, that's nothing if I'm just gonna get eaten up on Sunday in the race. So, I then certainly switched my mentality to it all. And again, I think a team will always respect you for having a go as opposed to, like this isn't the sport to sit back and be complacent. And now a word from our sponsors. When I was a kid, I would watch race car
如果我排位赛表现好，如果我在周日的比赛中被吃掉，那什么也不是。所以，我肯定改变了我的心态。再说一次，我认为车队总是会尊重你敢于尝试，而不是，这不是一个坐下来满足现状的运动。现在是赞助商时间。当我还是个孩子的时候，我会看赛车
during my brother, Mike loves racing, used to, for his birthday, I would buy him like, you know, racing around the track stuff. He lives for it, lived for it. He passed away, but hold for laughs. And so, no, he's great. He would have laughed at that. Your dad didn't run him over with the car leaving.
在我哥哥迈克喜欢赛车的时候，他喜欢，为了他的生日，我会给他买那种，你知道，在赛道上赛车的东西。他为它而活，曾经为它而活。他去世了，但停顿一下笑声。所以，不，他很棒。他会嘲笑那个的。你爸爸没开车把他撞倒吧。
He didn't, he's since, he was a great brother. I love him very much. But he loved race car driving. And, but when we were, when I was a kid, I was like, I don't, I don't know you's well enough to, it's okay to laugh because otherwise you'll cry. Oh, please laugh. Yes.
他没有，他自那以后，他是个好哥哥。我非常爱他。但他喜欢赛车。而且，当我们，当我还是个孩子的时候，我当时想，我，我不够了解你，笑是可以的，因为否则你会哭。哦，请笑吧。是的。
He would love us talking about him. He would love us laughing about him. He was the best brother ever. That rest his soul. Okay. So anyway, when I was a kid, he would be, he would make me watch race car driving. And I was like, as a kid, I don't get it. They pushed the gas and they go around that.
他会喜欢我们谈论他的。他会喜欢我们嘲笑他的。他是最好的哥哥。愿他安息。好的。所以总之，当我还是个孩子的时候，他会，他会让我看赛车。我当时想，作为一个孩子，我不明白。他们踩油门，然后绕着那个转。
What's the skill? Right? Right? And so, and I've heard other people say that. Of course, now that I'm older and understand it, there's tremendous skill about it. There's tremendous talent behind it. But what do you say to those people who don't quite understand that it's way more than that?
技巧是什么？对吧？对吧？所以我听过其他人这么说。当然，现在我长大了，理解了它，它有巨大的技巧。它背后有巨大的天赋。但你对那些不太理解它远不止于此的人说什么？
Like especially kids who can't understand it. Yeah. And even, I guess even like a grownups, like I'm not, I'm not mad about it. And because it's, it's simple. Like no one can really do it in terms of, like even me, if I wanted to drive my F1 car today, I couldn't, like it's, you know, so no one can really relate
就像尤其是那些无法理解的孩子。是啊。甚至，我猜甚至像成年人，我，我并不为此生气。因为它是，它很简单。就像没有人能真正做到，就像即使是我，如果我想今天开我的F1赛车，我也做不到，就像它是，你知道，所以没有人能真正产生共鸣
because it's just racing is such a niche thing. And, you know, like we can run around on a basketball court and understand that that is a physical sport. You know, like we can, we can do it and understand the, the stresses on your body. Sean, that's the one with the, with the hoop in the net. Oh God, let me write it. Yeah.
因为赛车是一件非常小众的事情。而且，你知道，我们可以在篮球场上跑来跑去，理解那是一项体育运动。你知道，我们可以，我们可以做到并理解对你身体的压力。肖恩，那是那个有篮筐和网的。哦天哪，让我写下来。是啊。
I tried to use like an American sport, I guess. But yeah, but racing, you know, like if they watch us on TV, it's like, well, yeah, I drive my car to work every day. So it's, it's kind of the same just faster. But what kind of car do you drive to work every day? Well, now it's a McLaren, which I'm pretty excited about. Yeah.
我试着使用像美国运动之类的，我想。但是的，但赛车，你知道，如果他们在电视上看我们，就像，好吧，是的，我每天开车上班。所以它，它有点一样，只是更快。但你每天开车上班开什么车？嗯，现在是迈凯伦，我对此很兴奋。是啊。
Now you can't really open that thing up in Monaco, right? I mean, the fastest anybody drives on those streets is when they close it off for that race. And even when that race track is all set up, it's very hard to pass on that track. Really any track that you guys are on. Cause listener, the formula one is all road courses. So you're turning left, you're turning right, you know,
现在你不能在摩纳哥真正打开那东西，对吧？我是说，任何人在那些街道上开的最快的时候就是他们为那场比赛封路的时候。即使当那个赛道设置好后，在那条赛道上也很难超车。真的，你们所在的任何赛道。因为听众朋友们，F1全是公路赛道。所以你在左转，你在右转，你知道，
whereas like NASCAR is a big circle or an oval and one might think that a driver would get dizzy because they're just going around and sorry, it's much easier to pass in that situation. And Sean, Sean, just so you know. So by the way, I came to know you Daniel, I think in a way that a lot of other, especially North American viewers got to know you was
而像纳斯卡是一个大圆圈或椭圆形，有人可能会认为车手会头晕，因为他们只是绕圈，抱歉，在这种情况下超车容易得多。肖恩，肖恩，你要知道。所以顺便说一句，我认识你丹尼尔，我想以一种很多其他人，尤其是北美观众认识你的方式是
on the Netflix show. 13 reasons why? 13 reasons why I drive? Drive to survive. Drive to survive. Drive to survive. Drive to survive. And so, and by the way,
在Netflix的节目上。《十三个原因》？《十三个原因》我开车？《极速求生》。《极速求生》。《极速求生》。《极速求生》。所以，顺便说一句，
you're the most personable guy on in formula one by a long shot. And I don't want to get into naming names, but there's some real duds out there. And- There is, there is. Yeah, there, oh my God, it must be fucking, it must be God, you have to suffer some of these fools.
你是F1中最有个性的人，遥遥领先。我不想点名，但外面有一些真正的笨蛋。而且——确实有，确实有。是啊，天哪，那一定是该死的，那一定是天哪，你必须忍受这些傻瓜。
And there's some really cool guys. You know, I like a lot and tell me if I'm wrong. I like that guy Toto who runs Mercedes. He seems like a really cool character, right? He's a cool guy. He's cool. He's definitely got a presence. But he's, I would say very, very good at what he does.
而且有一些非常酷的家伙。你知道，我喜欢很多，如果我错了请告诉我。我喜欢那个经营梅赛德斯的托托。他看起来像个很酷的角色，对吧？他是个酷家伙。他很酷。他绝对有存在感。但他，我会说非常，非常擅长他的工作。
How much socializing is there between teams? Like when you guys get to a destination, are teams or drivers hanging out and going to dinner and stuff like that? Or does everyone kind of stay with their own team for the most part? Yeah, not much. Like maybe after a race,
车队之间有多少社交？就像当你们到达目的地时，车队或车手会聚在一起吃晚饭之类的吗？还是每个人基本上都和自己的车队待在一起？是啊，不多。就像也许比赛结束后，
if we're staying there the Sunday night for whatever and there might be like a, call it a party or something like you might end up having a drink with another driver, but it's funny. It's a very individual sport. Yet it's not because our team, like McLaren has two cars. And there's probably 800 people as part of that team itself.
如果我们周日晚上因为什么事待在那儿，可能会有个派对之类的，你可能会和其他车手喝上一杯，但这很有趣。这是一项非常强调个人的运动。但其实也不完全是，因为我们的车队，比如迈凯伦有两辆车。而作为车队本身，大概有800人。
So it's- You and Lando Norris, for instance, who's the other driver for McLaren this year. Do you guys spend a lot of time together? No, away from the track, no. No. And I imagine that's common, right? Most drivers, even if you're on the same team,
所以，比如你和兰多·诺里斯，他是迈凯伦今年的另一位车手。你们俩花很多时间在一起吗？不，在赛道外，没有。没有。我想这很常见，对吧？大多数车手，即使在同一个车队，
don't really hang out with one another, yeah? You just end up kind of staying to yourself. I say stay to yourself. Like I do get on with other drivers, but it's- You're talking to your mechanics and your team, the rest of your team that's, yeah? Yeah, like on a race weekend, yeah, if we were to go out for dinner,
也不会真的和对方混在一起，对吧？你最终还是会保持独处。我说保持独处。我是说我和其他车手相处得不错，但主要是……你是在和你的机械师、你的车队，以及你团队的其他成员交流，对吧？是的，比如在比赛周末，如果我们要出去吃晚饭，
it's yeah, you kind of take like your mechanics and your race engineers to dinner and then I'll have like my little kind of personal crew, whether it's my trainer and my agent or whatever. Oh, nice. You got like an F1 entourage. Sure. I want to go back to the 800 people.
你会带上你的机械师和赛车工程师去吃饭，然后我会有我的小团队，不管是我的训练师还是经纪人什么的。哦，真不错。你还有F1随行人员。当然。我想回到那800人的话题。
There's 800 people per team. Sean, you can't believe the apparatus. It's wild. But why so many people? Like what do they do? It's so, this like- I mean, you don't have to tell me what each one of them-
每个车队有800人。肖恩，你简直不敢相信这套装置。太疯狂了。但为什么这么多人？他们都做什么？这太……我是说，你不用告诉我他们每个人都……
Yeah, you need them all to travel to each one of these. Talk to us about how that, like is there a plane? Is there a 747, like a air transport thing where you put all the cars on it? The touring bus that you need in the paddock? Like how do you get everything all over the world? I guess like within Europe, you guys can drive around trucks,
是的，你需要他们所有人去参加每一场比赛。跟我们说说这是怎么运作的，比如有飞机吗？有波音747那种空运工具把所有车都装进去吗？还有你在围场需要的巡回巴士？你们是怎么把所有东西运到世界各地的？我想在欧洲，你们可以开卡车到处跑，
but if you're going from Hungary and then you've got to go to Australia, how does that happen? So that's all through flight. And I'm pretty sure DHL's been like a partner of F1 for years and years. So that's all managed through them. But-
但如果你要从匈牙利去澳大利亚，那是怎么做到的？那都是通过空运。我很确定DHL多年来一直是F1的合作伙伴。所以这一切都是通过他们管理的。但是……
Oh, so each team doesn't have their own cargo transport plane. You guys kind of sub that out with these- I believe so. Your cargo carriers, I got- I believe so, I should probably know. But yeah, I'm pretty sure. But like after a race,
哦，所以每个车队没有自己的货运飞机。你们是把这些外包给……我想是这样。你们的货运承运商，我……我想是这样，我应该知道的。但是的，我很确定。但比赛结束后，
the cars will get like stripped down, put into big containers. Oh, all right. And then away they go. At a race weekend, there's a limited amount of personnel per team. So I think it's roughly maybe 80 that will travel like part of the traveling circus per team.
赛车会被拆解，装进大集装箱里。哦，好吧。然后它们就运走了。在比赛周末，每个车队的人员数量是有限的。所以我认为大概有80人会作为巡回马戏团的一部分随队出征。
But then yeah, at the factory, there's air-dynamicists, there's strategy engineers, there's like it's wild. And then because it's a business. The only track we have here in the US is in Austin, right? In Texas? Yes. Yeah.
但之后在工厂里，有空气动力学家、策略工程师，这太疯狂了。而且因为这是一门生意。我们在美国唯一的赛道是在奥斯汀，对吧？在德克萨斯州？是的。是的。
And then we're going to Miami next year as well. Are you going to Miami? Oh, that'll be fun. I can't wait to be there as your guest, Daniel. So- That was so nice of you, Daniel. Thank you. Listen, I'm going to be in the pit.
明年我们还要去迈阿密。你要去迈阿密吗？哦，那会很有趣。我迫不及待想作为你的客人去那里了，丹尼尔。所以……你真是太好了，丹尼尔。谢谢。听着，我会待在维修区。
You need me in the pit. I don't know- I've been in the pit during a couple of Formula One races back in the day. It's so nerve-wracking because at least for me, I just felt like there are certain things you can't see as a guest. Really?
你需要我在维修区。我不知道……我以前在F1比赛时去过几次维修区。那太让人紧张了，因为至少对我来说，我觉得有些东西作为客人是看不到的。真的吗？
Yeah, you get inside the garages. Like there's private stuff in there about the way they set stuff up. And so you're afraid you might look at the wrong thing. It's so loud. Pictures and stuff? Yeah, there's little pictures. Something to watch.
是的，你进入车库内部。里面有一些关于他们如何设置装备的私密信息。所以你担心自己可能会看到不该看的东西。而且太吵了。照片之类的？是的，有小照片。有些东西可以看。
I was buddies with Jacques Villeneuve for a half a second. And he invited me and my buddy to the race in Germany, the race of Monaco and- Oh, so you've done a few. Nice. A couple of, yeah. It's actually, the only time I've ever been arrested, I was picked up on the incline in Monaco.
我和雅克·维伦纽夫做过一小会儿的朋友。他邀请我和我的哥们去德国站和摩纳哥站的比赛，然后……哦，所以你参加过几次。不错。参加过几次，是的。其实，我唯一一次被捕，就是在摩纳哥的斜坡上被带走的。
Oh, yeah? I was knocked out and was woken up by a cop picking me up off the ground in the middle of the night on the incline. Why were you knocked out? What happened? Like a dream. Did I not tell you the story?
哦，是吗？我当时被打晕了，半夜在斜坡上被一个警察从地上扶起来才醒过来。你为什么被打晕了？发生了什么？像做梦一样。我没跟你讲过这个故事吗？
No. Well, I mean, let's tell everybody. Well, it's just us, right? So I was over-served in the casino in the grand casino. I don't know- Over-served? Yeah.
没有。好吧，我是说，我们告诉大家吧。反正只有我们，对吧？所以我当时在赌场，在大赌场喝多了。我不知道……喝多了？是的。
I mean, it's completely irresponsible of them. But so I'm gambling- Sir, are you sure that you would like another? You've had 30 drinks already. So I'm gambling like I think I'm James Bond and I'm winning all these large, like rectangular chips. And I'm in a leopard suit. You heard me?
我是说，他们那样做完全是不负责任的。但我当时在赌博……先生，您确定还要再来一杯吗？您已经喝了30杯了。所以我赌博时觉得自己像詹姆斯·邦德，赢了所有这些大的、长方形的筹码。而且我穿着豹纹套装。你听到了吗？
Are you? I'm in a leopard- Shirt and tie, shirt and tie or t-shirt? No, there's no tie. It's wide open down to the naval and this leopard suit made by Costume Nationale. I mean, it was super, douche-douche level was super high for me.
你是吗？我穿着豹纹……衬衫和领带，衬衫和领带还是T恤？不，没有领带。领口大开到肚脐，这套豹纹套装是Costume Nationale做的。我是说，对我来说，那种“混蛋”指数简直爆表了。
It was, I was 20 maybe, I think. Well, yeah, what year was this? Cause it's highly relevant. Oh yeah, it was like, let's see. If I was 20, it was, it was 89, hello math, or 90, 90 or something like that. Yeah. I was born in 89.
当时我大概20岁吧，我想。好吧，那是哪一年？因为这很重要。哦，对了，让我想想。如果我20岁，那是……89年，嘿，数学，或者90年，90年左右。是的。我是89年出生的。
Does that make you feel old? We're in a fight. Yeah, it should. So anyway, so I'm all banged up and it's four in the morning and I need to ride back to my hotel, which is just outside the city and I can't find a cab. So I'll walk by this newspaper truck,
这让你觉得自己老了吗？我们要打一架吗？是的，应该的。所以总之，我浑身是伤，当时是凌晨四点，我需要回城外的酒店，但我找不到出租车。所以我走过一辆报纸卡车，
local newspaper truck. There's stuff in the newspaper boxes cause it's four in the morning with today's new paper. And I say to these guys in English cause I don't know French, where are you guys headed? Can I get a ride to my hotel? And of course they looked at me like one might, you know, with not much of a response.
当地的报纸卡车。报纸箱里有东西，因为是凌晨四点，有当天的报纸。我用英语对这些人说，因为我不会法语，你们要去哪儿？能载我一程去酒店吗？当然，他们看着我的眼神就像……你知道，没什么回应。
They just kind of ignored me. So of course that upset me cause as, as I said, I'm banged up and so as I- That's not you though. That's a French thing. Yeah, but he's- No, but still, I mean, come on. A drunk American asking some guys
他们只是无视了我。所以这当然让我很不爽，因为正如我所说，我浑身是伤，所以当我……那可不像你。那是法国人的作风。是的，但他……不，但还是，我是说，拜托。一个喝醉的美国人问几个正在
filling up a newspaper box for a ride to, I mean, come on. So, so they told me to get lost. And as I walked by their truck, I just kind of smacked the side of their panel truck, you know, just out of frustration. Mondia. Yeah. Next thing I know, I'm, I'm waking up
往报纸箱里装报纸的人要搭车，我是说，拜托。所以，他们叫我滚蛋。当我走过他们的卡车时，我出于沮丧，拍了一下他们的厢式货车侧面。Mondia。是的。下一刻，我醒过来时，
but everything sideways cause I realize I'm, I'm on my side on the incline. They knocked me out, I guess. Cause they're pissed off at me. And it's a van that rolls up into my vision and the side door opens up. It's like a Wes Anderson movie. And a cop gets out of the van cause it's a cop van.
一切都是侧着的，因为我意识到我正侧躺在斜坡上。我想他们把我打晕了。因为他们对我火大。然后一辆面包车出现在我的视野里，侧门打开了。就像韦斯·安德森的电影一样。一个警察从车里出来，因为那是警车。
And I go, oh, this is so great. You guys are going to be able to take me to my hotel. They pull me in. They say, you can't be drunk in Monaco. They take me to jail. They put me in the drunk tank, which is one of the most beautiful rooms I've ever seen. By the way.
我说，哦，这太棒了。你们能带我去酒店了。他们把我拉进去。他们说，在摩纳哥不能喝醉。他们把我带到监狱。他们把我关进醉酒拘留室，顺便说一句，那是我见过最漂亮的房间之一。
There's a- You can't be drunk in Monaco. Sounds like a Pet Shop Boys song. There's a beautiful sort of Angora Pajmina sitting there in the drunk tank for me to keep myself warm. And I wake up in the morning to the sound of qualifying cause cause the little jail,
那里有……在摩纳哥不能喝醉。听起来像宠物店男孩的歌。醉酒拘留室里有一条漂亮的安哥拉羊绒毯子让我保暖。早上我被排位赛的声音吵醒了，因为那个小监狱，
the little cop stations right there near the pits. And so that was the engines wake me up and I've broken the heel on my shoe. Okay. So with these- Oh, you're wearing heels. Yeah, it's sort of like- You should have mentioned you're wearing leopards and leopard skin and heels.
那个小警察局就在维修区附近。所以是引擎声把我吵醒了，而且我鞋子的后跟断了。好吧。所以这些……哦，你穿着高跟鞋。是的，有点像……你应该提到你穿着豹纹和高跟鞋。
And like sort of platform groovy shoes. I mean, I don't know. So I've got the extra heel or the broken heel in my pocket along with the chips. And the cops want to know if I want to file charges cause I have a dislocated shoulder. Against yourself? That's what I realized.
还有那种厚底的时髦鞋子。我是说，我不知道。所以我口袋里装着多余的鞋跟或断掉的鞋跟，还有筹码。警察问我想不想起诉，因为我肩膀脱臼了。起诉你自己？我就是这么意识到的。
From looking that way? That's basically they said, okay, so you're sure you want to file charges? Cause you know, you're in violation of being, you know, drunk in public or whatever. And I just had screwed and I'd kind of got in the cabin, got home and nursed my hangover and my dislocated shoulder.
从那个角度看？他们基本上是说，好吧，你确定要起诉吗？因为你知道，你违反了公共场合醉酒之类的规定。我只是说去他的，然后我打到了车，回到家，处理了我的宿醉和脱臼的肩膀。
But that's the only time I've been arrested in Monaco. Daniel, thank you for coming today. Yeah, Daniel. Thanks so much to hear that Jason's story of debauchery. It's one of many. So Daniel, you won Monaco in 2018. Mm, you know your stuff. That's pretty good, right?
但那是我在摩纳哥唯一一次被捕。丹尼尔，谢谢你今天能来。是的，丹尼尔。非常感谢听到杰森那段放荡的故事。这只是其中之一。所以丹尼尔，你在2018年赢得了摩纳哥站。嗯，你很懂行。那很棒，对吧？
How great was that feeling winning Monaco is, cause it's the most famous- That's the granddaddy. Right, isn't it? It is like the, let's say the ultimate, is the world title, that's obviously what you want. And if you don't get that or let's say a runner up to a world title is, is twinning Monaco.
赢得摩纳哥站的感觉有多棒，因为它是最著名的……那是鼻祖。对吧，不是吗？它就像是，我们说是终极目标，世界冠军当然是你想要的。如果你没拿到那个，或者说世界冠军的亚军就是赢得摩纳哥站。
It's like the, it's the crown jewel. And it's even from, I mean, that the circuit is so intense and it's so tight and it's so easy to crash there basically. So kind of like putting it together on that weekend. And then with the kind of just the aura of Monaco. And I like 2018 was special because two years before that in 2016, I was leading and we had a slow pit stop. And then Lewis passed me during my pit stop
它就像是皇冠上的明珠。而且即使从……我是说，那条赛道太紧张了，太窄了，在那里撞车太容易了。所以在那周末把一切都做好。再加上摩纳哥那种光环。我喜欢2018年，因为它很特别，因为两年前的2016年，我当时领先，但我们进站慢了。然后刘易斯在进站时超过了我，
and he ended up winning the race. So I was so dark after that because it was, it's not often, obviously you get a chance to win Monaco. And it was obviously a childhood dream and- What does dark look like for you? I mean, is it just, you're just hitting the bong every day and watching cartoons like it's just-
他最终赢得了比赛。所以我当时非常沮丧，因为赢得摩纳哥站的机会并不多。这显然是儿时的梦想，而且……对你来说“沮丧”是什么样子的？我是说，你每天都在抽大麻看动画片吗，就像……
Are you a Hufford like me? Yeah, you're- Or do you climb into the Krispy Kreme's like Sean? Oh, hey, they're good. So yeah, maybe for my levels of dark, it was dark, but it was actually funny because that, so the 2016 year, let's say the dark year on the podium, I was dark, call it, and I wasn't smiling.
你是像我一样的瘾君子吗？是的，你是……或者像肖恩一样钻进甜甜圈里？哦，嘿，它们很好吃。所以，也许以我的沮丧程度来说，那是沮丧，但其实很有趣，因为那一年，2016年，那个沮丧的年份，在领奖台上，我很沮丧，我没笑。
And all the things that were kind of set about me after that weekend, other than like how unlucky I was was, oh my God, like Ricardo can, he actually can get mad. He can get angry because everyone just knows me. So obviously just smiling and obviously loving it and having a good time. But it was just funny that I think everyone just thought, like, I don't have the ability to feel hurt or anger.
在那周末之后，关于我的一切说法，除了我有多倒霉之外，就是“天哪，里卡多竟然真的会生气”。他真的会发火，因为每个人都了解我。所以显然只是微笑，显然很享受，玩得很开心。但有趣的是，我想每个人都以为我没有感到受伤或愤怒的能力。
And they were like, oh, somebody poked the bear. Here he comes. And he did. I want to know something like, I don't know anything about you personally. Did you have somebody to celebrate your win with? Are you married, you have a girlfriend, you have children? Easy, Sean.
他们就像是，哦，有人捅了马蜂窝。他来了。他确实来了。我想知道一件事，我个人对你一无所知。你有可以一起庆祝胜利的人吗？你结婚了吗，有女朋友吗，有孩子吗？冷静点，肖恩。
So I don't, I don't, I'm not married, no kids. I had, so I was very, I was very fortunate because 2018, the year I won, I had mom and dad there. I had some of like my best mates there who were kind of obviously there to see me, but also like coincidentally doing a bit of a Europe trip at the time. So.
所以我没有，我没结婚，没孩子。我有……我很幸运，因为2018年，我获胜的那一年，我爸妈都在那儿。我还有一些最好的朋友在那儿，他们显然是去见证我的胜利，但也巧合地在那时进行了一次欧洲旅行。所以。
Oh, the Aussies love to get around the world, don't they? Oh, yeah. They love, oh, coming soon to a bar near you, drunk Aussies. I mean, am I right? I know, I. I love them though. I love Aussies. I love hate.
哦，澳大利亚人喜欢环游世界，不是吗？哦，是的。他们喜欢，哦，即将来到你身边的酒吧，喝醉的澳大利亚人。我是说，我说得对吗？我知道，我。但我爱他们。我爱澳大利亚人。我爱恨。
I love, as a Canadian, I love you Aussies. Yeah, Americans love Aussies. I do. I love Aussies and I love Australia. I've been, I've been a number of times. I think it's an awesome, awesome place. So, so you've got all your friends over there. You got mom and dad, but you've got no significant other.
作为一个加拿大人，我爱你们澳大利亚人。是的，美国人爱澳大利亚人。我爱。我爱澳大利亚人，我爱澳大利亚。我去过很多次。我觉得那是一个非常、非常棒的地方。所以，你有所有的朋友在那儿。你有爸妈，但你没有另一半。
No. Have you ever been in a relationship is what Sean wants to know. Yeah. Yeah, I have. And I think like long story short, it is hard. Yeah, I bet with the schedule, yeah. The schedule and you kind of need it for the sport,
没有。肖恩想知道你有没有谈过恋爱。是的。是的，我有过。我觉得长话短说，这很难。是的，我敢打赌，因为赛程安排，是的。赛程安排，而且你为了这项运动需要它，
but it kind of teaches you to be selfish, you know, like you, you have to kind of go all in to like your own basket. And even like, oh, notice, even like with family or friends, because Formula One is so intense and everything's like so strict on time. And if a mate is late for dinner by like 10 minutes, I'm pissed.
但这也会教会你变得自私，你知道，你必须把所有筹码都押在自己的篮子里。甚至对家人或朋友也是如此，因为F1太紧张了，一切时间都非常严格。如果朋友迟到10分钟吃晚饭，我会很生气。
I'm like, mate, you've wasted 10 minutes of my time. So some things that I've kind of grown with the sport, I do resent in like my personal life, but it's kind of a necessary evil, if you will. But you do have self-care in the sense that like, I noticed, you know, you do, you live in Monaco, and I guess you spent a lot of time over in the UK because that's where McLaren is based.
我会说，伙计，你浪费了我10分钟。所以有些我随着这项运动成长起来的东西，我在个人生活中确实很反感，但这是一种必要的恶，如果你愿意这么说的话。但你确实有自我照顾，我注意到，你知道，你住在摩纳哥，我想你花了很多时间在英国，因为迈凯伦总部在那里。
So you must go back and forth quite a bit to the UK, is that right? I'm guessing. Yes. So, Dax said you are an Anglo-file. What? I had to look up what that meant. No, you misread it.
所以你一定经常往返于英国，对吧？我猜。是的。所以，达克斯说你是个“亲英派”。什么？我得查查那是什么意思。不，你读错了。
You said asshole. Dax said that about me. He said you're an Anglo-file, which is that someone who like wants to be British or something like that? Something like that. But it just has a great deal of sort of reverence for. And I'd say guilty is charged.
你说的是“混蛋”。达克斯是那么说我的。他说你是“亲英派”，就是那种想成为英国人或者类似的人？类似那样。但它只是对某种东西有极大的敬意。我会说“认罪”。
But, and I can't, and I love that Dax said that because it always makes Dax laugh. Cause every time I would mention like, oh yeah, I was with my friend and he'd go, let me guess, your bunny's from London. You know, oh, Barney's always got, cause he calls me Barney. Well, his Dax impression is.
但是，我喜欢达克斯那么说，因为它总是让达克斯发笑。因为每次我提到，哦，是的，我和我的朋友在一起，他就会说，让我猜猜，你的朋友来自伦敦。你知道，哦，巴尼总是……因为他叫我巴尼。好吧，他的达克斯模仿秀是……
It's so good, right? Yeah, it's good. Wait, do you know like in other sports, Daniel, the, like in football and stuff, people, there is a ceiling of, when you reach a certain age, is that true in your sport as well? Do people age out or are there people of a certain age still doing it?
太棒了，对吧？是的，很好。等等，你知道在其他运动中，丹尼尔，比如足球之类的，人们，当你达到一定年龄时是有上限的，在你的运动中也是这样吗？人们会因为年龄大而退役吗，还是有一定年龄的人还在做？
I would say it's uncommon to go like beyond 40. I wonder why that is because, because. Reaction time. Oh yeah. Yeah, I would say it's got to do with maybe some, yeah, like reflexes and that. And you can't be a fatty either, right? You gotta, you gotta fit in those small cars.
我会说超过40岁是不常见的。我想知道为什么，因为……因为反应时间。哦，是的。是的，我会说这可能和一些……是的，比如反射神经之类的有关。而且你也不能是个胖子，对吧？你得塞进那些小车里。
Here we go. Yeah. Oh, here we go. Let's talk to me about how you manage your water weight and everything. What do you do when you drink a lot of electrolytes or? So it's very like, as soon as we tell someone how much we lose during a race,
开始了。是的。哦，开始了。跟我说说你是如何控制水分流失和一切的。当你喝很多电解质时你会做什么？所以这非常……一旦我们告诉别人我们在比赛中流失了多少，
just 3S sweat and obviously fluids, it's everyone's like, I need to become an F1 driver. I need to lose weight in two hours. What are you good for about? By the way, you're about to make Bateman cry when you tell him how much you lose. Let me guess, you drop between five to 10 pounds in water weight per race.
只是汗水和显然的液体，每个人都会说，我需要成为一名F1车手。我需要在两小时内减肥。顺便问一下，你大概流失多少？你快要把贝特曼说哭了，当你告诉他你流失了多少时。让我猜猜，你每场比赛流失5到10磅的水分。
Yeah, exactly. Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? Is that true? I would say on average around like two and a half kilos, which is, well, it's like maybe seven pounds. Wait, how do you do that? How do you do that so quickly?
是的，没错。你在开玩笑吗？你在开玩笑吗？那是真的吗？我会说平均大概两公斤半，也就是，嗯，大概7磅。等等，你怎么做到的？你怎么能这么快做到？
From sweat, dude? Oh, just sweat, okay. Yeah. Is there any way we could just put Jason's face in an F1 car? Could we just do that just so it could lose? I could take two to three kilos out of my face right now. It'd be great.
靠出汗，伙计？哦，只是出汗，好吧。是的。有没有办法我们可以把杰森的脸放进F1赛车里？我们能那样做吗，只是为了让他减肥？我现在能从脸上减掉两到三公斤。那太棒了。
I can only see like, basically from rest of the bumps. It looks okay from here. They shouldn't be breasts. They should be pectorals. So. Let's start there. Yeah. And what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
我只能看到，基本上从肿胀的其余部分来看。从这里看还可以。那不应该是胸部。那应该是胸肌。所以。从那开始吧。是的。我要做的是，我要
just tilt my camera up. Oh no, oh no, there's the angel. Look at the sweet name. Wait, so what I was gonna say before was, so you spend a lot of time in the UK, but then could you go back and forth and fuck backs, but then you also spend, you also live in Los Angeles, part of the time.
把我的摄像头向上倾斜。哦不，哦不，那是天使。看看那甜美的名字。等等，我之前想说的是，你花了很多时间在英国，但你可以往返，但你同时也花时间，你也住在洛杉矶，部分时间。
You own a house in Los Angeles, quite near all of us, I think. Not that I've Googled, but I have. Weird. And it is. And I think we're practically neighbors, Daniel. What's in the garage over there? Yeah, that's what I was gonna,
你在洛杉矶有一栋房子，我想离我们所有人都很近。并不是我谷歌过，但我有。奇怪。而且确实是。我想我们实际上是邻居，丹尼尔。那边的车库里有什么？是的，我正要……
that was my next question. What's your LA car? So being the Bogan Australian that I am, we call them utes back home, but because we don't really have anything big enough to call a truck. So when I got my place in the States, I was like, first thing I'm buying is a Raptor.
那是我的下一个问题。你的洛杉矶座驾是什么？作为一个土气的澳大利亚人，我们在老家叫它们“ute”，但因为我们没有足够大的车可以叫卡车。所以当我在美国有了住处时，我想，我买的第一件事就是猛禽。
So I have a Raptor. Oh, this is the most disappointing thing you said. First of all, it's so inland empire. No, it's so inland empire of you. First of all, A. Your GMC contract is safe, Will. Let me just say this. Friends don't let friends drive Fords.
所以我有一辆猛禽。哦，这是你说过最让人失望的话。首先，这太“内陆帝国”了。不，这太“内陆帝国”了。首先，A。你的GMC合同很安全，威尔。让我这么说吧。朋友不会让朋友开福特。
You know, GMC, GMC Sierra is a tremendous vehicle. Is this a clock? Will's been doing the commercials for GMC for what is it, Will, 25 years? 22, coming up on 23 years up in the voice of GMC trucks. Are they professional grade? Well, they are professional grade, Jason. Thank you for asking.
你知道，GMC，GMC Sierra是一辆了不起的车。这是个时钟吗？威尔为GMC拍广告拍了多久了，威尔，25年？22年，快23年了，作为GMC卡车的代言人。它们是专业级的吗？好吧，它们是专业级的，杰森。谢谢你的提问。
Okay. Yeah, he's the guy. Look at Daniel, I'm seeing, this is the first moment I've seen Daniel's face, respect you, Will, right there. Yeah. He just was like, oh my God. I'm gonna drive over to your house
好吧。是的，他是那个人。看看丹尼尔，我看到了，这是我第一次看到丹尼尔的脸，尊重你，威尔，就在那儿。是的。他只是觉得，哦，天哪。我要开车去你家，
and a brand new GMC Yukon XL Denali, Daniel, and I am gonna make a convert out of you. Wait, so you spend time in Los Angeles. My point was this. That kind of must be for you the real getaway because Formula One is not huge in California. In Australia, I imagine you're a, I know you're a bit of a superstar
开一辆全新的GMC Yukon XL Denali，丹尼尔，我要让你成为信徒。等等，所以你花时间在洛杉矶。我的观点是这个。那对你来说一定是真正的度假，因为F1在加州并不火。在澳大利亚，我想你是一个，我知道你是一个超级巨星，
and Australia loves you and they've embraced you. When you're in Europe, everybody watches Formula One and so that you're getting not harassed, but like your Daniel Ricardo F1 champion driver, you come to Los Angeles, it's kind of you get to have a little- You can walk around. Yeah, you can walk around and kind of have a life, right?
澳大利亚爱你，他们拥抱了你。当你在欧洲时，每个人都看F1，所以你受到的不是骚扰，而是像“你是丹尼尔·里卡多，F1冠军车手”，你来到洛杉矶，你有点……你可以四处走动。是的，你可以四处走动，过上生活，对吧？
Is that, am I right with that? I'm blushing now, but anyways, LA, like you're right, like there's two main reasons, like F1 is not very existent there. So you kind of can, it's more for me as well to like mentally get away from the sport and switch off. And I'm not surrounded by F1 people or F1 enthusiasts. So it is like a good escape.
是这样吗，我说对了吗？我现在脸红了，但总之，洛杉矶，你是对的，F1在那里几乎不存在。所以你可以，对我来说更多是为了在精神上远离这项运动并关掉开关。我没有被F1的人或F1爱好者包围。所以这确实是一个很好的逃避。
And then it also reminds me a lot of home, you know? It is like- A lot of us, you see that. We've got the weather, we've got the beaches. Yeah, it's like a bigger version of home. So there's like, I won't lie like, there's a bit more to do there. So it's entertaining for me,
而且它也让我想起很多家乡的事，你知道？它就像……我们很多人，你看到了。我们有天气，我们有海滩。是的，它就像一个更大版本的家。所以，我不会撒谎，那里有更多的事情可以做。所以对我来说很有趣，
but I can also just kind of switch off and lay low if I like as well. Sure. And now a word from our sponsors. What's the workout like? What's the keeping in shape like for Formula One? Is it, how, you know, I'm kind of the guy, you know, in this podcast, I'm kind of the workout guy.
但我也可以关掉开关，保持低调，如果我愿意的话。当然。现在是赞助商时间。锻炼是什么样的？F1的保持身材是什么样的？是，怎么说，你知道，我是那种人，你知道，在这个播客里，我是那种锻炼的人。
And I'm the guy who's known for the workout. Dushing weight around, yeah. He's got you contemplated right now, but- You can tell. I could see your, I could see your pictorials. And there it is. Thank you. Oh no, Jason got breasts and I got pictorials.
我是那个以锻炼闻名的人。推举重量，是的。他现在让你沉思了，但是……你可以看出来。我能看到你的胸肌。就在那儿。谢谢。哦不，杰森有了胸部，我有了胸肌。
You sure do. So hurtful. So wait, so, but in all seriousness, what is that, what is that like in terms of- I got pastes. You have to be in great, you've got to be in great, Jesus. You've got to be in great shape to do that. And we talked about losing all that water weight.
你确实有。太伤人了。所以等等，但说真的，那是什么样的，关于……我有膏药。你必须处于极好的，你必须处于极好的，天哪。你必须处于极好的状态才能做到这一点。我们谈到了流失所有那些水分。
I mean, it's demanding physically, isn't it? Being in those cars, just doing one race. So there's a few challenges to come with, let's say like the physical demand of the sport is that it's a lightweight sport. So I think in the perfect circumstances, we would be like a lot heavier than what we are in terms of just, I think we'd love to put on more muscle
我是说，这在身体上要求很高，不是吗？待在那些车里，只跑一场比赛。所以有一些挑战，比如这项运动的身体要求是它是一项轻量级运动。所以我认为在完美的情况下，我们会比现在重得多，就……我想我们很乐意增加更多肌肉，
if we could. And why we need the muscle is basically for the G forces. So like Silverstone, for example, the track in England, through some parts of the circuit, we're pulling like 5.5, so five and a half Gs through the corner, like it's wild. So- Is that because of the speed of the turn
如果我们可以的话。我们需要肌肉的原因基本上是为了G力。所以比如银石赛道，英国的赛道，在赛道的一些部分，我们在弯道中承受着5.5，也就是5.5个G，这太疯狂了。所以……这是因为转弯的速度，
or the fact that the turn is so flat that there's no sort of banking that can offset the Gs? It's mainly the speed of the turn. So there's like, there's several corners where seventh, eighth gear. So there's eight gears in an F1 car. And yeah, so like one of them, well, two of them are eighth and it's, I don't know, like whatever,
还是因为转弯太平坦，没有可以抵消G力的坡度？主要是转弯的速度。所以有几个弯道是七档、八档。F1赛车有八个档位。是的，所以其中一个，嗯，两个是八档，我不知道，不管怎样，
190 mile an hour through some of these corners. And we're just, so we need like a lot of strength through our neck, our core. Don't need a lot of leg strength though, do you? Do you ever work your legs? So like our right leg, not crazy for the accelerator, but for the brake. I think if anyone drove, got to like drive an F1 car,
在这些弯道中时速190英里。我们只是……所以我们需要脖子、核心有很大的力量。不需要很多腿部力量，对吧？你锻炼腿部吗？所以我们的右腿，对于油门来说不疯狂，但对于刹车来说。我想如果有人开车，能开F1赛车，
that probably the biggest thing they'll say is how hard you have to smash the brake pedal. Oh wow, really? To get like performance out of it. Yeah, it's mainly like, yeah, I guess, glute and carve, like so we do like some stuff for that. But again, we kind of have to do all endurance based. I feel like I could do okay with that.
他们可能会说的最大的一件事就是你必须多用力踩刹车踏板。哦哇，真的吗？为了从中获得性能。是的，主要是，是的，我猜，臀部和腿肚子，所以我们确实做了一些那方面的训练。但同样，我们必须做所有基于耐力的训练。我觉得我能应付那个。
Cause I've got a pro, I've been in this company is having a pro dumper. And so like I have a lot of glute strength. You sure do. I'm tough to get off the puck because I have this pro dumper that I can kind of get. So I'm just, yeah. No, we got it.
因为我有一个职业……我一直在这家公司有一个职业阻尼器。所以我有很多臀部力量。你确实有。我很难离开冰球，因为我有这个职业阻尼器，我可以……所以我只是，是的。不，我们明白了。
So the, you know, what they teach you is to drive with one foot. You know, unless you're driving a stick shift and you got to work the clutch with the left foot, you guys don't have a clutch, yet you're still using the left foot for the brake. I think you guys are doing it wrong. I think it's unsafe.
所以，你知道，他们教你用一只脚开车。你知道，除非你在开手动挡，你必须用左脚操作离合器，你们没有离合器，但你们仍然用左脚刹车。我觉得你们做错了。我觉得这不安全。
Well, tell them what to do. Yeah, no, just use just the right foot. So you're either on the gas, or if you need to come off the gas and get on the brake, you still use the right foot. They probably haven't even thought of that. I don't, it's not gonna start that, you know, which is safer.
好吧，告诉他们该怎么做。是的，不，只用右脚。所以你要么踩油门，或者如果你需要松开油门去踩刹车，你仍然用右脚。他们可能甚至没想过那个，你知道，哪个更安全。
Okay, so, so, yeah. Now, do you miss a clutch, don't you? No, let him tell you why they don't, Jason. Let him tell you. I don't know really. I don't know anything. It's here, explain the mistake. It's, no, it's okay.
好吧，所以，是的。现在，你怀念离合器，不是吗？不，让他告诉你为什么他们不怀念，杰森。让他告诉你。我真的不知道。我什么都不知道。在这里，解释一下这个错误。不，没关系。
So actually in a road car, I will do right foot braking. And I think because there's also like a lack of urgency on the road, you know, so you like, you've got time to get off the throttle, get on the brake. We're in racing, we nearly overlap, you know, like as soon as we come off the throttle, we're smashing the brake.
所以实际上在公路车里，我会用右脚刹车。而且我认为因为路上也缺乏紧迫感，你知道，所以你有时间松开油门，踩上刹车。我们在赛车中，我们几乎重叠，你知道，一旦我们松开油门，我们就在猛踩刹车。
Gotcha. And the steering column runs right down the middle, kind of in between our legs. So to get our right foot across, I don't even know if it's physically possible. I got you. And then you've got all the buttons on the steering wheel. Those are all the shifting the gears and shit.
明白了。而且转向柱就在中间，就在我们腿之间。所以要把右脚跨过去，我甚至不知道这在物理上是否可能。我明白了。然后方向盘上有所有的按钮。那些都是换挡和乱七八糟的东西。
Yeah, so we do have a clutch, but it's on the steering wheel. So it's like a hand clutch. So you're engaging the clutch as you change the gears or no, don't you just, isn't it on demand? Just for the start. So just to take off, we use the clutch, and then it's all just weakened like flat shift.
是的，我们确实有离合器，但它在方向盘上。所以它是一个手控离合器。所以你在换挡时接合离合器，还是不，不是按需吗？只是为了起步。所以只是为了起飞，我们使用离合器，然后一切都只是……平顺换挡。
I want to know, when you said you go to Los Angeles and you to chill out and everything, do you like the brakes in between races or are you just constantly thinking about it, waiting to get back and you love it so much? Or does your brain need the brake from constantly going? I think I've always had like, yes, racing is my passion, but I've always loved just other things as well.
我想知道，当你说明你去洛杉矶放松时，你喜欢比赛之间的休息，还是你一直在想它，等着回去，你太爱它了？还是你的大脑需要从不断的奔波中休息一下？我想我一直有，是的，赛车是我的激情，但我一直也喜欢其他事情。
Like I don't live and breathe it. So yeah, I do enjoy brakes. I do enjoy doing other stuff. What do you like doing? Yeah, what do you like to do? What do you like? Where can Sean take you next time you're in LA? Yeah, that's a great question.
我不靠它生活和呼吸。所以是的，我确实享受休息。我确实喜欢做其他事情。你喜欢做什么？是的，你喜欢做什么？你喜欢什么？下次你在洛杉矶时，肖恩能带你去哪儿？是的，那是个好问题。
You like tapas? I love, I love, I love sports. I'm a big sports fan. So like just seeing live sport makes me happy and live music. Isoccy. I love music.
你喜欢塔帕斯吗？我爱，我爱，我爱运动。我是个大体育迷。所以看现场体育比赛让我快乐，还有现场音乐。Isoccy。我爱音乐。
Jack, Jack. Wait, wait, wait, wait, did you say Isoccy? You like Isoccy? You know what? I have not been, but I would love to go to a game. Well done, consider it done. Okay, so you guys F1 and then I'll be a guest at Isoccy. I think he just told us to fuck off, didn't he?
杰克，杰克。等等，等等，等等，你说Isoccy？你喜欢Isoccy？你知道吗？我还没去过，但我很想去看一场比赛。做得好，算你赢。好吧，所以你们F1，然后我会成为Isoccy的客人。我想他刚才叫我们滚蛋，对吧？
Wait, what? So you guys F0, I'm pretty sure that's what he said. Will you rewind that real quick? F1, F1. Okay, so now listen, so you like watching sports? You like... You're a gamer, I assume you're a gamer. No.
等等，什么？所以你们F0，我很确定他就是这么说的。你能快速倒带一下吗？F1，F1。好吧，现在听着，所以你喜欢看体育比赛？你喜欢……你是游戏玩家，我假设你是游戏玩家。不。
Oh, really? No. You'd be good at gaming. Yeah, but I'm the kind of cooler generation. Like I'm a bit past that. So I'm all you guys on that level. No, no, don't misunderstand Will. He's got a headset probably just out of frame.
哦，真的吗？不。你玩游戏会很厉害。是的，但我属于那种酷一代。我有点过了那个年纪。所以我在那个层面上和你们所有人一样。不，不，别误解威尔。他可能就在画面外戴着耳机。
Why did you tell him we're just becoming best friends? He and I are about to be better friends than him in DAX. Tell him where to find you. You know, what's your handle? Is it, are you a gamer? Is this like, I'm a little bit of a gamer. It should be noted for a guy who's 51, who has very little gray hair by my dad
你为什么告诉他我们正成为最好的朋友？他和我要成为比他和达克斯更好的朋友了。告诉他去哪儿找你。你知道，你的账号是什么？是，你是游戏玩家吗？这是像……我有点是游戏玩家。应该指出的是，对于一个51岁的人，我爸的头发很少有灰白，
and probably looks at like more like 32. You're looking at me like, hey, we're the same age or whatever. I'm surprised. Did you say 31? Thank you so much, Daniel. We've noted that and that is on the record officially. We just cut our teaser. You don't, so you don't, you don't game,
看起来更像32岁。你看着我，就像，嘿，我们同岁之类的。我很惊讶。你说31岁？非常感谢，丹尼尔。我们记下了，这正式记录在案。我们刚剪辑了我们的预告片。你不，所以你不，你不玩游戏，
you like to watch sports, you like to play sports. You like to play basketball, right? I know that you like to sort of keep active in that way. What others, like, are you like a big movie guy? What do you do? You have so many. How do you fill your day? You travel all the time.
你喜欢看体育比赛，你喜欢玩体育比赛。你喜欢打篮球，对吧？我知道你喜欢以那种方式保持活跃。还有什么，比如，你是电影迷吗？你做什么？你有这么多。你怎么打发时间？你一直在旅行。
So I love playing sports, but on the movie thing, it reminded me of, so I, so some of my like core friends from back home in Perth, like some childhood friends, we, so I won't see them for like a year. Like I'll get home for Christmas and, and they're pretty good. Like they know not to like pest me with racing questions
所以我喜欢玩体育，但在电影方面，它让我想起，所以，我的一些来自珀斯老家的核心朋友，一些儿时的朋友，我们，所以我可能一年见不到他们。比如我圣诞节回家，他们很不错。他们知道不要用赛车问题来烦我，
and they don't really care too much either. And we will, we will like sit around a table and have a few drinks and for hours, our conversation is just movie dialogue. It's just movie quotes and it's, it's the most immature conversation. That's true. Yeah, I, that reminded me very much of what a lot of,
而且他们也不太关心。我们会围坐在桌子旁喝几杯，几个小时，我们的谈话全是电影台词。全是电影引用，这是最幼稚的谈话。那是真的。是的，我，那让我想起了很多……
What have you loved lately that's come out? Cause I, I'd start like imagining that you guys would be laughing about some comedies that come out. I mean, I, I mean, to you, Will and to Sean too, like what, there's, there's, there's been like a great comedy film that's come out for a while. Game night. Game night was hilarious.
最近有什么让你喜欢的电影出来吗？因为我，我开始想象你们会因为一些出来的喜剧而大笑。我是说，我是说，对你，威尔，还有肖恩，有什么……有一部伟大的喜剧电影出来很久了。《游戏之夜》。《游戏之夜》太搞笑了。
By the way, there it is. Game night. That's all I'm fishing for. Thanks. We can move on. I'm actually being totally honest. It's a great. I'm being totally truthful.
顺便说一句，就在那儿。《游戏之夜》。那是我想要的一切。谢谢。我们可以继续了。我其实是完全诚实的。这是一个伟大的。我完全是真诚的。
That is one, that is one of the last times I laughed out loud in a movie. I agree. You guys did a great job with that. Game night, when it came out a couple of years ago, I've told you, it's so good. And I say this to Jason all the time. I want him to do more pure comedies
那是我在电影里最后一次大笑的时刻之一。我同意。你们做得很好。几年前《游戏之夜》出来的时候，我告诉过你，它太棒了。我一直对杰森这么说。我希望他多拍纯喜剧，
cause he is the funniest dude. And it's one of the only nice things I'll say about him today. But the other thing is, have you guys seen, and I told him this when I saw, and I watched it again last night with my kids and I shouldn't have, it's a little irresponsible. I watched Palm Springs with my kids.
因为他是最搞笑的家伙。这是我今天对他说的唯一好话之一。但另一件事是，你们看过吗，我看到时告诉过他，我昨晚和孩子们又看了一遍，我不应该看，这有点不负责任。我和孩子们看了《棕榈泉》。
Have you guys seen that Sandbergs movie that Andy Sandbergs movie from last year? It didn't Bennett's brother direct that. And our friend Bennett's brother directed it. Max Barbacow directed it. It is a brilliant movie. It's so funny. Daniel, watch this movie,
你们看过那部桑德伯格的电影，去年那部安迪·桑德伯格的电影吗？不是贝内特的兄弟导演的吗？我们朋友贝内特的兄弟导演的。马克斯·巴巴考导演的。那是一部精彩的电影。太搞笑了。丹尼尔，看这部电影，
Palm Springs with Andy Sandberg. It's a phenomenal movie. I really. That'll give me a nice little California fix watching that. So you will love it. Speaking of Sandbergs, that reminds me of Hot Rod. And so one of like the worst lines ever that I'll randomly say at times is boom, there's the flavor.
安迪·桑德伯格的《棕榈泉》。这是一部非凡的电影。我真的。那会给我一个很好的加州修复，看着那个。所以你会喜欢的。说到桑德伯格，那让我想起了《热血大叔》。所以其中一句最烂的台词，我有时会随机说出来，就是“砰，味道就在那儿”。
Is that a will or a net line? Will, are you in that? Yeah, this is a will or a net line. You say boom, there's the flavor? Yeah. All my friends will look at me and it's so random. Give Daniel a quick live reading of that right now. I don't do this.
那是威尔还是内特的台词？威尔，你在里面吗？是的，这是威尔或内特的台词。你说“砰，味道就在那儿”？是的。我所有的朋友都会看着我，这太随机了。给丹尼尔现场读一下。我不做这个。
Just three, two. And action. There's the flavor. Oh, there you go. Sully, you showed. What do you say? I gotta kick you in the nuts or something. Sully, I say, what do I say?
三，二。开始。味道就在那儿。哦，给你。萨利，你展示了。你说什么？我得踢你的蛋蛋之类的。萨利，我说，我说什么？
I think I owe you a nut shot. I barely, I did that movie with Sandberg and those guys, the Lonely Island guys and I Kiva directed it and Yorma's in it and I went up to shoot in Vancouver and I got a really bad cold on the way up there. And so I was on cold medicine for the few days that I was there. I barely remember being there.
我想我欠你一脚踢蛋。我几乎，我和桑德伯格还有那些家伙，孤独岛的家伙们拍了那部电影，基瓦导演的，约尔马也在里面，我上去温哥华拍摄，我在路上得了很严重的感冒。所以我去那里的几天一直在吃感冒药。我几乎不记得在那里了。
I was on so much cold medicine. And so I did all of that stuff, like even that when I'm yelling out all that, babe, babe, babe. I was just doing it to make those guys laugh. And also, I guess I was just in some kind of other, I was high, I guess, on cold medicine. Well, Jesus, well, hang on a second.
我吃了太多的感冒药。所以我做了所有那些事，比如当我大喊大叫时，宝贝，宝贝，宝贝。我只是为了让那些家伙笑。而且，我想我当时确实处于某种其他状态，我猜，因为感冒药。好吧，天哪，威尔，等一下。
I mean, what we don't like, Robotussin or Ferraflu? Like this doesn't get us high. No, I was on, I was on a thing that was called Christal Methamphetamine. Yeah, yeah, there we go. Yeah, I'm gonna have to have a little side chat with you after this session. Christal.
我是说，我们不喜欢，止咳糖浆还是感冒冲剂？这不会让我们嗨。不，我当时在吃一种叫“冰毒”的东西。是的，是的，就是那个。是的，这次会议后我得和你私下聊聊。冰毒。
Oh, Daniel. Daniel, we've taken up way too much of your time. I gotta say, I'm just such a fan of how you hold yourself. I've been watching you go from Red Bull to Renault and then now you're with McLaren and you've just always, truly always have a smile on your face in the best way. You had a great race at Silverstone.
哦，丹尼尔。丹尼尔，我们占用了你太多时间了。我必须说，我真的很喜欢你的处事方式。我看着你从红牛到雷诺，然后现在你在迈凯伦，你总是，真的总是带着微笑，以最好的方式。你在银石赛道跑了一场精彩的比赛。
Your fifth place was great. I feel like you're just, you're coming back into your own and you just, you're such a great dude and an awesome driver to watch and it's been such a pleasure to meet you. Yeah, such a pleasure to meet you. Thank you for coming on. Yeah.
你获得第五名真是太棒了。我觉得你正在找回状态，你真是个很棒的家伙，也是一位非常值得一看的赛车手，能见到你真是太荣幸了。是的，见到你真是太荣幸了。谢谢你来参加节目。是的。
Very, very nice. Thanks, I thoroughly enjoyed it. It was good to meet you all as well. You too. Wait, wait, last question is, and so how do you, so you and Dax are friends? I gotta get to the bottom of this. Yes, so I went on his podcast last year
非常好，非常棒。谢谢，我非常享受这次交流。见到你们大家也很高兴。我也是。等等，等等，最后一个问题是，你是怎么，所以你和Dax是朋友吗？我得弄清楚这件事。是的，我去年上了他的播客。
and so one other thing, I love his bikes. I love motorbikes. Oh, he loves motorbikes. Yeah, so we kind of hit it off through talking bikes. And then yeah, when I was, I spent, I actually couldn't get home for Christmas because of the quarantine and all the, Sure.
还有一件事，我喜欢他的摩托车。我喜欢摩托车。哦，他喜欢摩托车。是的，所以我们通过聊摩托车一拍即合。然后，是的，当时我，我实际上因为隔离和所有那些，当然。
Let's say the craziness with Australia. So I spent Christmas in LA and we caught up and we went riding and stuff. So yeah, we hit it off like two school kids. Yeah, he loves that stuff. He's the friend of all of ours and he was our first guest that we had on our podcast because we love him so much and so I get it.
咱们说是澳大利亚那边的疯狂情况吧。所以我圣诞节是在洛杉矶过的，我们聚了聚，还一起去骑车什么的。所以，是的，我们就像两个小学生一样一拍即合。是的，他喜欢那些东西。他是我们所有人的朋友，也是我们播客的第一位嘉宾，因为我们太喜欢他了，所以我明白。
Two good guys having fun on motorcross that none of us do. So we can't join you on that. But anyway, well, what a pleasure, man. Thank you for coming by and wish you all the success and can't wait to see you in Miami. The three of us are gonna be there with you in Miami. Yeah, we're really looking forward to that. Should we just call, we'll just,
两个好家伙在玩我们都没玩过的摩托车越野。所以我们没法加入你们。但不管怎样，真是太荣幸了，伙计。谢谢你过来，祝你一切顺利，迫不及待想在迈阿密见到你。我们三个会在迈阿密和你在一起。是的，我们真的很期待。我们应该打个电话，我们只是，
we'll call you once you're down there or should we call you beforehand? When we land, we'll text you when we land. You just send the laminates over to the hotel. Okay, great. I was gonna offer to pick you up in the jet on the way. It's a D tour, but I can do that. That sounds better.
等你到了那边我们再给你打电话，还是我们应该提前打？我们落地时会给你发短信。你只要把通行证送到酒店就行。好的，太棒了。我本来想提议在路上用私人飞机去接你。虽然绕路，但我可以做到。那听起来更好。
Even better, even better. Even better, we love jets. We love jets. All right, well, you go get your thoughts together. You've still got time to hit the casino tonight, I'll bet. And make sure you arrange transportation before you get in there. And a pleasure talking to you, my friend.
更好，更好。更好，我们喜欢私人飞机。我们喜欢私人飞机。好了，那你去整理一下思绪吧。我敢打赌你今晚还有时间去赌场。确保你在进去之前安排好交通工具。很高兴和你交谈，我的朋友。
Yeah, thanks, Daniel. Such a pleasure. Best of luck the rest of the season. Thank you. So yeah, likewise, I thoroughly enjoyed it. And I hope you guys are enjoying it as well. We are. This is all relatively new for you, right?
是的，谢谢你，丹尼尔。真是太荣幸了。祝你赛季余下时间好运。谢谢。所以，是的，同样，我非常享受这次交流。希望你们也喜欢。我们很喜欢。这对你来说相对较新，对吧？
Yeah, it is. About a year, yeah. And we are loving Formula One. It's amazing and it's so good. And I'm rooting for you every single week. Thank you. Keep it going. All right, pal.
是的，确实。大约一年吧。我们非常喜欢一级方程式。它太棒了，真的很好。我每周都在为你加油。谢谢。继续保持。好了，伙计。
We'll see you guys soon. Thank you. Thanks, buddy. Thank you. Cheers. Bye, bye, bye. See ya. Will, a very classy booking there. Right?
我们很快会再见到你们。谢谢。谢谢，伙计。谢谢。干杯。再见，再见，再见。回头见。威尔，那次预约真是太有档次了。对吧？
Yeah, really cool. I know nothing about it. I really, really, really do want to do, try what he does once. I really want to do that race track thing where you go, right? I'd probably be going like 40 miles now. We'll go to Monaco and just show up
是的，真的很酷。我对此一无所知。我真的，真的，真的想做，尝试一次他所做的事情。我真的很想去体验那种赛道，就是你去的那种，对吧？我可能只会开到每小时40英里。我们要去摩纳哥，然后直接出现，
and just say, hey, can I pop in? Yeah, that'd be so cool. There's a place in Atlanta I can take you to, or even here in LA. Yeah, go up to Willow Springs. I really do want to do that. Yeah, you should. It's a really fun thing to do.
然后说，嘿，我可以加入吗？是的，那会很酷。亚特兰大有个地方我可以带你去，或者就在洛杉矶这里。是的，去柳泉赛道。我真的想去。是的，你应该去。那是一件非常有趣的事情。
Or just do that Toyota Grand Prix along beach. Do they still do it? It's a celebrity race. I think they do. I think I'd love to do that again. We should do that. I'll do that together. I'll joke aside.
或者就去参加那个长滩丰田大奖赛。他们还在办吗？那是名人赛。我想他们还在办。我想我愿意再做一次。我们应该一起做。不开玩笑了。
You know that Jason's won it three times? Are you serious? I've done it four times, and I think I've finished first, second, third, and fourth. I think that's right. Wow, I didn't know that you liked to do that. And then I foolishly accepted an invite from Mitsubishi to race professionally
你知道杰森赢过三次吗？你是认真的吗？我参加过四次，我想我分别拿过第一、第二、第三和第四名。我想应该是这样。哇，我不知道你喜欢做那个。然后我愚蠢地接受了三菱的邀请，去参加职业比赛，
for a couple of races. What? In their sport truck series. And I raced. When was this? This was when I was 23 or something like that. And I raced, my professional career lasted two races. I raced, or no, three maybe.
参加了几场比赛。什么？在他们的运动卡车系列赛中。我参加了。这是什么时候的事？那是我23岁左右的时候。我参加了，我的职业生涯持续了两场比赛。我参加了，或者不，也许是三场。
It was a limerock, and then maybe it was two, and then Pocono. And there was a spill in front of me. And this guy was skidding across the track, and I T-boned him. And my car, or truck, it was a sport truck, flew up in the air, we were doing about 130, landed on its roof, and skidded to a stop.
那是莱姆石赛道，然后也许是两场，然后是波科诺。我前面发生了一起事故。那个人在赛道上打滑，我撞了他的侧面。我的车，或者说卡车，那是辆运动卡车，飞到了空中，我们当时时速大约130英里，车顶着地，滑行停下。
And the impact was so hard that it sent my front left tire up through the wheel well and broke my left ankle. And after I said I'd do a stop, I was like, okay, that'll do it for the professional stuff. I'll let my cheesy celeb ass get out of here and let the real men work. Oh, wow. Wait a second, I did not know this.
撞击力太大了，导致我的左前轮穿过轮拱，折断了我的左脚踝。在车停下后，我说，好吧，职业生涯到此为止了。我还是让我的名人身份退场，让真正的男人去工作吧。哦，哇。等等，我不知道这件事。
I knew everything. No, there's a whole actual sequential of this crash that National Enquirer got back in the day, which was so great for me, because I got to see it, because it wasn't televised, it was a silly little race. Anyway. That's wild. I didn't even know that you had done this, though.
我以为我知道一切。不，当时《国家询问报》拿到了一整套关于这次撞车的连续照片，这对我来说太棒了，因为我能看到它，因为它没有被电视转播，那只是一场愚蠢的小比赛。总之。太疯狂了。不过我甚至不知道你做过这个。
That's what's so crazy. I mean, I've spent hours when you and Amanda are away going through your stuff, like in your house, and like, and then- Well, why don't you have me on the show? You should have me on the show, why don't you have me on the show? We should have you on the show.
这就是最疯狂的地方。我的意思是，当你和阿曼达不在家时，我花了好几个小时翻看你的东西，比如在你的房子里，然后——好吧，你为什么不邀请我上节目？你应该邀请我上节目，你为什么不邀请我上节目？我们应该邀请你上节目。
It'd be great to finally meet the real you. Hard schedule. It is hard to schedule. Is it? Yeah. But how great is Daniel Bell? I mean, talk about, it does boggle my mind, and I like what you said, John, which is like, how do you, what is that feeling
终于见到真实的你一定会很棒。日程很难排。很难排吗？是的。但丹尼尔·里卡多有多棒？我的意思是，谈谈这个，这确实让我感到困惑，我喜欢你说的，约翰，就是，你怎么，那种感觉是什么，
that first time going around? I know, because when you get, that's what I want to experience. I want to do that. What is that when you're allowed to speed? Right. Right? Yeah. When you are given permission to go over 110, 20, 30, 50,
第一次绕圈的感觉？我知道，因为当你得到，那才是我想要体验的。我想做那个。当你被允许超速时，那是什么感觉？对吧。对吧？是的。当你被允许超过110、20、30、50英里时，
whatever that is. I remember Dax flew through Frankfurt, and he, because he wanted to go to that famous, what's that famous track that you can go to? Like on Sundays, it's open to the public. The Nürburgring. Nürburgring. So Dax goes and he rents a, through like Hertz,
无论那是多少。我记得Dax飞过法兰克福，他，因为他想去那个著名的，那个你可以去的著名赛道是什么？就像周日，它对公众开放。纽博格林。纽博格林。所以Dax去了，他租了一辆，通过赫兹租车，
he rents a Porsche to pick up at the airport in Frankfurt. I did the same thing, except I got mine in Monaco and drove it all the way up there. Which is probably, it was fun. Realized too late, it was $5 a mile. Oh, are you serious? Yeah. Wow. True story. Wow.
他在法兰克福机场租了一辆保时捷。我也做了同样的事，除了我是在摩纳哥租的，然后一路开到那里。这可能，这很有趣。太晚才意识到，那是每英里5美元。哦，你是认真的吗？是的。哇。真实的故事。哇。
Well, at that time, it was probably five lira. I mean, think about it, if it was you. It was a long time ago. Yeah, it was a long time ago. I paid in spices and rugs. So Dax likes at Frankfurt, and he goes to like, Avis or Hertz, whatever, and he goes, so they're like, they give him the keys to the Porsche,
好吧，在那个时候，那可能是5里拉。我的意思是，想想看，如果是你的话。那是很久以前的事了。是的，那是很久以前的事了。我用香料和地毯支付的。所以Dax在法兰克福，他去了安飞士或赫兹，随便哪家，他说，他们给了他保时捷的钥匙，
and he goes, how do I get to the Nürburgring? And they're like, I'm very sorry, but you cannot take this car on the Nürburgring, of course. It goes without saying, you cannot do that. He goes, oh yeah, no, no, no, I'm not going to do it. But anyway, how do I get there? And they're like, we are very serious. You must not take this car to on the thing.
他说，我怎么去纽博格林？他们说，非常抱歉，但你当然不能把这辆车开到纽博格林。不用说，你不能那样做。他说，哦，是的，不，不，不，我不会那样做的。但总之，我怎么去那里？他们说，我们是非常认真的。你绝对不能把这辆车开到那个地方。
And he goes, no, I totally won't, I totally won't. But so just tell me which way. And of course, he got in it. I think K-Vel was with him too, and they just drove out there, and he popped on that thing in this rented Porsche. He said it was wild. There was a sun, he's opened everybody.
他说，不，我绝对不会，我绝对不会。但就告诉我怎么走。当然，他上车了。我想K-Vel也和他在一起，他们就开车去了那里，他开着那辆租来的保时捷冲上了赛道。他说那太疯狂了。那是周日，对所有人开放。
He said there were like people going in trucks with like campers on the back, and then like dudes in Maserati's going 200 miles an hour. It's really cool. That'd be fun, right? If the three of us went and did that. Oh my God. Yeah, we'll save it for the European tour.
他说有开着后面带露营车的卡车的人，还有开着玛莎拉蒂以每小时200英里速度行驶的家伙。这真的很酷。那会很有趣，对吧？如果我们三个去做了那件事。哦，天哪。是的，我们留到欧洲巡演时做吧。
Oh, yes, for the European, shh. I'll talk about the European tour. Don't talk about the European tour. Don't talk about the European tour. Wait, are we going to do a domestic tour? What cities, what cities are you guys going to? We're already doing a domestic tour. Yeah, well, maybe we'll take this opportunity
哦，是的，为了欧洲，嘘。我会谈论欧洲巡演。不要谈论欧洲巡演。不要谈论欧洲巡演。等等，我们要进行国内巡演吗？你们要去哪些城市？我们已经在进行国内巡演了。是的，好吧，也许我们会利用这个机会，
to remind our listener. What's here? Oh, yeah, that's right there. Oh, yeah, sure, sure. What dates are there? Are it Toronto? Are you going to go to Toronto? We're going to go to Toronto.
提醒我们的听众。这里有什么？哦，是的，就在那里。哦，是的，当然，当然。有哪些日期？是多伦多吗？你们要去多伦多吗？我们要去多伦多。
Where would you go after Toronto? And what dates are you going to be in Toronto? We're going to Boston. Are there any tickets left even? I go to New York. There are a few tickets left. It's like a smartlist.com. Wait, what?
去完多伦多你们要去哪里？你们什么时候去多伦多？我们要去波士顿。还有剩下的票吗？我去纽约。还有几张票。就像Smartlist.com。等等，什么？
It's a merch. What's it called? Smartlist.com. Can you spell that? You know what, my favorite thing, though, that he said all the entire interview is, bye, there's the flavor, bye, there's the flavor, is that what it was? That doesn't count. No, it's a boom. Sean, hang on.
那是周边商品。它叫什么？Smartlist.com。你能拼一下吗？你知道吗，我最喜欢的是，他在整个采访中说的是，再见，这就是风味，再见，这就是风味，是这样吗？那不算。不，那是砰的一声。肖恩，等等。
I got to pause for a second. Please. That was so fucking sloppy. It was sloppy. It was aggressive. He said in an hour, you know? You just sitting there fucking cherry picking, waiting to do the bye. What happened?
我得暂停一下。请。那太他妈草率了。太草率了。太激进了。他说在一小时内，你知道吗？你只是坐在那里他妈的挑三拣四，等着说再见。发生了什么？
Did your toaster just go off? Like all of a sudden you had to get out of there? What the fuck is going on with you? My Ezekiel Brad just went off. That's just gross. Christ almighty. How about instead of, you don't need to do that. If you want to just wrap up, how about just look at us like an adult and just look at both of us and just go, Daniel, Ricardo, it was great for him to be here today.
你的烤面包机刚响了吗？就像突然你必须离开那里一样？你他妈到底怎么了？我的以西结面包刚烤好。那太恶心了。天哪。与其那样，你不需要那样做。如果你想结束，不如像个成年人一样看着我们，看着我们俩说，丹尼尔·里卡多，很高兴他今天能来。
Even if it was just a drive. Bye. Oh, beautiful with the drive and everything. Bye. Bye. Drive. Bye. Bye.
即使只是开车。再见。哦，开车什么的太美了。再见。再见。开车。再见。再见。
Drive. Bye. Drive. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
开车。再见。开车。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。